this episode is brought to you by secure
frame secure frames industry-leading
compliance automation platform paired
with their in-house compliance experts
and former Auditors helps you to get
audit ready in weeks not months so you
can close more deals faster I pulled a
ton of you online on social and reviews
came back which were overwhelmingly
positive for secure frame secure frame
simplifies and streamlines the process
of getting and staying compliant to the
most rigorous Global privacy and
security standards they help thousands
of businesses achieve compliance with
security and privacy Frameworks
including sock 2 ISO 27001 HIPAA PCI and
gdpr secure frame is the most
comprehensive security and compliance
automation platform with hundreds of
Integrations built-in security training
vendor and risk management and more you
continuously detect and remediate
misconfigurations across your technology
stack you also get complete visibility
with actionable insights on critical
security and privacy compliance issues
security training for sock 2 HIPAA PCI
DSS gdpr and more are built into secure
frames platform you can quickly meet
security and privacy compliance
requirements and save time assigning
tracking and Reporting on required
training secureframe provides unmatched
expert guidance every step of the way
with their 30 plus former Auditors and
Industry professionals secureframe helps
you quickly achieve and maintain
compliance so you can focus on other
things like serving your customers
scaling your business and growing
Revenue so consider automating your
security and privacy compliance with
secure frame schedule a demo today at
secureframe.com as it sounds
secureframe.com and tell them Tim
Ferriss that's me Tim Ferriss sent you
to unlock 10 off for your first year
again that's secureframe.com and during
your demo tell them that Tim Ferriss
sent you to unlock 10 off for your first
year one more time secureframe.com
please
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep temperature is one of the main
causes of poor sleep and heat is my
personal Nemesis I've suffered for
decades tossing and turning throwing
blankets off pulling the back on putting
one leg on top and repeating all that ad
nauseam but now I am falling asleep in
record time why because I'm using a
device it was recommended to me by
friends called the Pod cover by eight
sleep the Pod cover fits on any mattress
and allows you to adjust the temperature
of your sleeping environment providing
the optimal temperature that gets you
the best night's sleep with the Pod
covers Dual Zone temperature control you
and your partner can set your sides of
the bed to as cool as 55 degrees or as
hot as 110 degrees I think generally in
my experience my partners prefer the
high side and I like to sleep very very
cool so stop fighting this helps based
on your Biometrics environment and sleep
stages the Pod cover makes temperature
adjustments throughout the night that
limit wake-ups and increase your
percentage of deep sleep in addition to
its Best in Class temperature regulation
the Pod cover sensors also track your
health and sleep metrics without the
need to use a wearable so go to
atesleep.com Tim allspelled out
eightsleep.com Tim and save 250 on the
eight sleep pod cover that's
eightsleep.com Tim H sleep currently
ships within the US Canada and the UK
select countries in the EU and Australia
again that's eightsleep.com Tim to save
250 on the eight sleep pod cover optimal
minimum at this altitude I can run flat
out for a half mile before my hands
starts shaking so now I answer your
personal questions
foreign
girls ladies and germs this is Tim
Ferriss welcome to another episode of
the Tim Ferriss show where it is my job
to interview and deconstruct world-class
performers to tease out the stories the
routines the habits the beliefs that you
can emulate to improve your own lives my
guest today is a fan favorite he's been
on once before he always delivers a lot
of actionable advice and learnings his
name is Richard Kosh k-o-c-h Richard is
an entrepreneur investor former strategy
consultant and the author of several
books on business and ideas including
four on how to apply the 80 20 principle
in all walks of life his Investments
have grown at an average of 22 percent
compounded annually over 37 years and
have included filofax Plymouth gin belgo
Betfair FanDuel and Auto one for those
who don't have any reference for that
that is absurdly absurdly good he has
worked for Boston Consulting Group and
was a partner at Bain and Co before
joining Jim Lawrence and and Evans to
start lek which expanded from 3 to 350
professionals during the six years
Richard was there in 1997 Richards
booked the 80 20 principle reinterpreted
the Pareto rule which states that most
results come from a small minority of
causes and extended it Beyond its
well-known applications and business
into personal life happiness and success
the book Rewritten in 2022 has sold more
than a million copies been translated
into roughly 40 languages and has become
a business classic it was named by GQ as
one of the top 25 business books of all
time and it is a book that has had a
huge impact on my life and one that I
have recommended for at least a decade
at this point Richard's latest book is
unreasonable success and how to achieve
it he has two upcoming books 80 20
beliefs which identifies the very few
beliefs in our lives that strongly
influence what we do and therefore the
results we get and we talk about some of
these 80 20 beliefs in this conversation
as well as 80 20 day a collection of 365
short daily readings using the 80 20
philosophy to achieve the good life you
can find him online at richardkosh.net
again that's
richardkoch.net and on Twitter at
Richard Kosh 80 20. and now without
further Ado please enjoy a wide-ranging
I think very fun certainly very
actionable conversation with Richard
Kosh
foreign
Richard it is so nice to see you in
person and he's sitting across from you
it's so wonderful to see you sitting
across from me as well in my kitchen
table as well which is fantastic thank
you very much for coming absolutely at
your kitchen table in this beautiful
house which is full of natural light
looking out at all sorts of greenery the
birds in the background couldn't be more
pleasant and before we started recording
I
took a bath with Greg as I often do part
of my pre-game ritual and I walked past
a fireplace and there was a small square
piece of wood with three words on it
gambits
payout so gambits
payout and I thought I should ask about
that first because I'm sure there's a
story behind it what is the story behind
this well I'm an investor in a company
called what three words I don't know if
you've heard of what three words but the
basic idea is that there are trillions
of squares on Earth and each square is
about the size of just outside my front
door and it's a method of trying to
identify where people are in order to
have deliveries happen where the address
system is not particularly good so I'm
an investor in this company it's a
wonderful wonderful British company
could you explain just maybe by way of
example what that means so they're
satellite identified squares yes and you
don't even need to be online but it's
basically mapped and therefore anyone
that's got the key to it can deliver to
where someone is it was originally
designed by a guy who was in the music
business and he and his band and would
arrange to meet at Glastonbury or
somewhere but of course the classroom is
vast you know there's a huge field there
and they would always miss each other so
he reckoned that you know if you could
find a way of describing something which
was not a whole series of alpha numeric
things you know the a you know a huge
long meaningless thing but with three
English words it could be in any foreign
language as well then you would be able
to find exactly where the person was and
exactly where they get the stuff
delivered so they might want it in the
garage for example they might want it in
a different joining part of the house
and and so they basically spent a huge
amount of money mapping the whole world
into trillions of these little squares
and the system now works and car
manufacturers can use it in order to
provide directions and mapping and it's
a wonderful system and it's very very
economical there is you unique three
words for everyone if you're involved in
a car crash or accident of any kind you
can identify where you are to the
emergency services or to anyone else in
order to be found as quickly as possible
without any mistake without the
ambulance or the police going here and
there and you know basically trying to
find where you are so I didn't
anticipate going down this side Avenue
but it's interesting so I'll pursue it
and then we'll come back to the these
particular three words which hopefully
are not like doxing you and exposing you
in some strange public way but if for
instance I have something delivered to
my front porch and it's banana eggplant
Susan whatever it might be if I then
travel and have a car accident how does
that series of three words get mapped or
associated with the new location which I
couldn't have predicted the system would
be able to find where you were when a
completely different location you
wouldn't have those three words that'd
be a completely different three words I
see I see right associated with yeah the
police would have that all the Emergency
Services would have and so forth so all
you would have to do would be identify
where you are on the telephone you you
just basically drop a pin and then they
can find you wow and does that involve
some type of Hardware pairing where you
have some type of card or any piece of
Hardware that identifies where you are
to match it with the the database of the
system it requires you to actually have
the car right the part of the system I
see it so Mercedes is on the system
various other car manufacturers are and
they're going through the process of
basically signing up all the Bitcoin
manufacturers and some of the small ones
as well around the world well you know I
have to just say that you have such an
Eclectic range of investments in
seemingly well perhaps not seemingly
completely disparate
sectors and Technologies serving
completely different
I suppose well niched down customer
bases and not to say that they're small
some of them are very huge where do
these three words come in this is what
by complete coincidence I've got right
outside my front door and it's gambits
and payout now I'm a strategy guy I do
strategy in order to make money by a
venture capital Investments and gambits
yeah that's the strategy and then payout
is huge Bonanza and you know I don't
want to be big-headed but I've done very
well in my investments and you know the
payout is the operative word and that's
why we're sitting in this nice house and
all the rest of it yeah so aren't I
lucky I don't know everyone's going to
hate me they're going to think oh the
guy's so smug we don't like him no but I
think I think the numbers speak pretty
well to the track records I think it's
it's fair enough to say it would be more
concerning I think if you had the line
related to the 22 compounded annually
over 37 years and then we were sitting
in some back alley and you were eating
out of a garbage can that would be more
incongruous and cause more problems but
well lots of people come to see me and
they think that I've been a much more
palatial place and of course what
happens is that you buy somewhere and
you live in it I've been living in this
particular house in Portugal for some of
the year for I'm not very good at mental
arithmetic it's actually 15 years yeah
nobody can fact check you so it's okay
okay
and and so you know it's a nice place
but it's you don't get the impression
that it's you know it's not Versailles
yes I think it's very comforting it has
a comforting feeling to it what is it
called something like that in again
I've got a fish pond that I do all my
thinking on and the fish go round and
round and wait for me to feed them so
let me ask you this is going to be a
whole collection of diversions but
that's sort of how my mind works so in
the last conversation that we had
you mentioned the fish pond and you also
mentioned related to the fish pond and I
quote
Oh dear yeah occasionally I go and sit
on my fish pond with a notebook and say
it's time to think about some
Reflections I make a point of only doing
that when I'm in a good mood I never do
it when I'm actually feeling slightly
down it's something you do when you're
being expansive rather than when you're
doubting yourself could you
say a bit more about that if that is
still the case yes
what would you like me to say why is
that important because I think that many
people including myself if I'm feeling
stuck or overwhelmed or whatever that is
often when I Journal most but you do the
opposite it would say that's true that's
true I mean I know that you have made a
very good speech about fear and the
importance of people revealing their
fears and I thought to myself well maybe
I should do it now yeah you seem to be
doing just fine yeah because you know
I've I think I'm actually quite good at
being upbeat but I'm not very good at
being dumb but I've never had I mean I
obviously respect the fact that a lot of
people have mental problems with one
sort or another I've never felt down for
more in about three hours wow yeah and
well it's something to be very grateful
for yeah I would give you every dollar
and every one of my bank accounts to
trip to read for that what I'm very good
at doing is actually imagining upside
and a lot of people say the whole point
of being a venture capitalist is that
you think about the downside of what can
go wrong and arrest it I disagree with
that because in the Venture Capital
business you make a huge amount of money
on very few Investments and you probably
lose money on nearly all the rest that
hasn't actually been completely true
about me I've only lost money on
probably about three or four Investments
total loss and you got me beat on that
front too yeah
but mental health yeah Richard wants him
I'm very lucky I do genuinely believe
that I'm quite good at what I'm doing
but I have been unbelievably like every
single major investment has had an
inflection point somewhere which was
Pure Luck so before we get to the look
because of course by virtue of having
some systematic way of approaching and
vetting or finding and vetting
Investments you've systematized
increasing the surface area to which
luck can stick and I'm borrowing that
expression from someone else whose name
I'm sadly forgetting
before we get to that
let's talk about the journaling so not
when you're feeling down but when you're
feeling expansive what does that look
like let's do it in regard to
Investments and then we're doing it in
regard to more important things in life
but as far as Investments are concerned
what I say to myself is what are the
opportunities which we're not fully
exploiting and I'm a great believer Tim
there are always huge opportunities out
there they're out there but most people
don't grasp that most people don't
believe it and most people don't do
anything about it even if they believe
it and I'm one of the people who
actually is a mega mega Optimist in
regard to things that are important to
me and the Investments are quite
important to me so I try and imagine how
do we make a hundred times return on
this investment not how do we try and
make 10 times return and of course it
doesn't always work
and my success stories cluster in the
sort of you know 10 to 25 times total
investment because one of the things
that I do is if I've invested in a
company and it's going really well I buy
more shares in it so I increase my stake
in the company so the average return is
not going to be 100 times but on the
first tranche of the Betfair investment
it was a hundred times
so what I'm trying to say is how could
this be unbelievably successful what
would have to happen to make it
unbelievably successful and sometimes
it's relatively easy sometimes it's
actually not that difficult to do
can you give an example of a case where
it was maybe easier or simpler than
people would expect well Betfair is very
very good example because this was a
company which in the early days ran out
of money could you just for people who
didn't hear our first episode and I do
recommend everyone listen to the first
episode because there's a lot of history
and a lot of context
but these are independent episodes and
they can be treated as such but for
people who are not familiar with Betfair
would you mind just saying a sentence or
two about what Betfair is Betfair is the
world's largest by a huge margin the
world's largest betting exchange and
what a betting exchange means is that
you and I exchange bets now obviously we
don't do it in person we do it through a
website and it's all Anonymous but
nevertheless it's not a system that's
used for still the great majority of
betting in the world takes place with
bookmakers bookmakers of these horrible
things
now these are terrible people because
they've got big satchels you go to the
races
the horse races or the Greyhound races
and you see these people arrive with you
know satchels and of course you don't
really know how much is in there but
when they're going home they're bulging
because actually what they do is they
take a profit on each race and they
construct the book such that unless
there's a very very unusual movement in
the betting at the very last minute
they're totally covered they always make
a profit on each race the over round
depends on the number of runners in the
race but it the overround goes from 10
usually to about 25 and in a race with a
large number of horses such as the Grand
National it can be as much as 150 which
means that for every dollar that someone
wages
50 cents profit is made by the bookmaker
now on Races which are not as important
as the Grand National or have very few
horses in them it might be as little as
10 percent
but it's a huge amount of money and so
there was a guy called the black Andrew
black to be more formal and he came up
with this idea why don't we make an
electronic system like the stock market
where vets can go through this thing and
instead of people having to pay 10 or 20
to the bookmakers each time they pay two
percent two percent commission and they
only pay if they win so on average it
can be one percent
and so it's a hugely better it sounds
like a commercial advertisement does it
but you know I'm no longer on the board
of Betfair and I'm not terribly
sympathetic to them because they won't
let me lose enough money and that's
another story but
the amount of money that I lose
sometimes I win sometimes I lose on a
year if I'm actually losing money
they actually restrict the amount of
money I can put in as the new stake and
I try to tell them that you know I've
got a lot of money and I don't think
they believe me yeah so I've never gone
to the stage of actually sort of you
know sending in my audited financial
statements or anything like that but
yeah anyway so I'm out of favor with
Betfair and they're out of favor with me
but it's a wonderful system because if
you gamble a lot it means that your
money can go much further you can make
larger stakes and you can actually win
money with a bookmakers it's impossible
to win money over more than a very short
period of time because they close the
account yeah huge house advantage and
then they come to Alaska yeah so to come
back
okay it's a bad Fair disintermediation
sort of classic technology play in a
sense and you were saying
you're communing with the fish at the
fish pond notebook in hand maybe it was
not exactly the Fish Bond but the the
exercise will work
and you ask how could this be a 100x
return or how could this be an
extraordinary success and it was an
example of where there was perhaps a
simple tweak or addition or something
like that what did that look like
firstly the concept I just thought was
unbelievable because anyone who's a
serious gambler should be betting
through a betting exchange they should
not be betting through bookmakers that's
a really dumb thing to do but it was
easier than that because the company
started and I have to say this and I
hope they're not listening but the
people who started the company didn't
really know what they were doing and
they did no reason that they should have
known what they were doing I mean they
were brilliant in their own way Andrew
black did absolute genius but he'd never
worked in a company as a manager he'd
never worked in financial services he'd
never worked in government he'd been a
professional Gambler so he understood
gambling but he didn't understand
business and they were pretty thin in
terms of the other people who understood
business so they went around the city of
London this was back in 2000 the year
2000 and they tried to raise money from
professional Venture capitalists and
anybody else that would be a
professional so investment Banks and
people like that and they all came back
sort of you know totally incredulous and
said you haven't got anybody who's been
the chief executive of anything in your
company you haven't got any people
who've actually worked in business
before at a senior level
how do you expect us to give you money
for this idea however brilliant the idea
was and all of the professional people
the people who ran the Racing Post the
newspaper and all the rest of it took a
look at it and thought you know this
idea is not going to fly
it was perfectly obvious to me as
someone who was a gambler that it was
really attractive that you know my money
could go much further I can have bigger
bets and I wouldn't have to fatten the
sexuals of these horrible bookmakers so
it was a blinding glimpse of the obvious
that it ought to grow enormously but not
only that Tim it was growing so after
nine months they ran out of money they
raised money in the first round from
their friends and family
and people have mortgaged their houses
and you know they tried to put as much
money as possible in but they weren't
rich people and they didn't have a lot
of money so how's that game like yeah
exactly as well probably some of them
and so they ran out of money and then
they went back to all the people that
they'd seen before
professional Venture capitalists and
said we've run out of money can we have
some more and they said well we weren't
going to give you money in the first
place we're certainly not going to give
it to you now that you're on the verge
of bankruptcy it's important to look at
the causes of that
outflows if it's because they're growing
faster than you can manage that's the
quality it was growing at 30 a month
and then it went up to 40 I looked I
asked them what just tell me one simple
fact every month since you started over
the last nine months what were your
Billings and what was the growth rate
the numbers were tiny really tiny but
the growth rate was fantastic and at one
point they were growing at 60 and 100 I
think this was just about the time that
I put my money into it which meant that
their monthly revenues were doubling
and anyone who understands anything
about arithmetic and exponential growth
knows that that doesn't have to carry on
for very long before you have a very big
business and if I had a very big
business because they didn't have to
have betting shops and other premises
and they didn't have to have a whole lot
of overhead they had a fairly simple
internet system and that was great and
they spent money you know they had to
upgrade it over time as they got more
customers but the margins in the
business for them were very high they
were only taking two percent of the
total amount of money statement the
total amount money stake pretty soon
became very very large and their costs
were a fraction of that two percent so
it didn't take a genius sitting on the
fish pond to say hey if they continue to
grow at this rate for the next five
years or even if it went down to 10
percent of months then I'm going to make
a fortune address and I put as much
money as I got into that company it was
a million and a half pounds of times all
the spare cash that I had and then when
the opportunity came to buy shares from
some of the early investors I pone it up
again where did you get the money to
Pony up from successful Investments that
I've made before I see so there was some
intervening period yeah first of all I
invested in filofax and that made us
seven times return this was in the 1990s
then I invested in belgo the mule fruit
restaurant mussels and chips french
fries and that made me uh six times
return and then I invested in Plymouth
gin where I was incredibly lucky which
is another story but we happened to get
the
top sport on the ratings of the experts
on gin the PVC television got together
30 experts so-called in tasting gin and
the Gin which they selected did they all
have the last name cash
we didn't even pay them any money no I
mean we didn't know this was going on we
got a call from that's called a drink
that's called BBC and said you might
want to tune in at seven o'clock in the
evening wow we had no idea that was a
very lucky investment and we sold it to
Vin and sprit which was the Swedish
state liquor Monopoly which owned
absolute vodka and they paid us more
than they should have done for the
company and what you know we made a 16
times return on that so let's let's hit
pause for a second so a couple of things
I want to mention first is we're going
to segue into sort of a broader Lane
outside of venture capital I do want to
say you're mentioning the uh
not bookies what was the what was the
term that you used the nasty horrible
bookmakers bookmakers yes who take the
percentage I will say that has an
uncanny resemblance to some Venture
capitalists not all who rely on their
management fees and not their
performance bonuses as a friend said to
me he went to business school and there
was a very famous I won't mention it by
name venture capitalist who is teaching
a class and he said venture capital is a
lot like sex he said when it's good it's
great and when it's bad it's still
pretty good
but you certainly
have the multiples to speak to the Bona
fides let's take a step back and this
actually relates to our conversation
over dinner last night where we were
having some very very nice white wine
with mackerel one of my favorites if
you're not eating mackerel folks I tell
you you're losing out in any case I
asked everyone around the table what
they studied in school so we can expand
on this but you mentioned history and I
asked a number of follow-up questions so
how is it that you go from studying
history to being the successful founder
of strategy consulting firm and private
Equity slash Venture Capital firm do
those things tie together yes they're
absolutely tied together because history
is great at teaching you just think so
history is all about counterfactuals you
know what could have happened as well as
what did happen what were the causes of
the first world war why did Lenin manage
to establish the communist state which
lasted for 70 years why did Hitler who
was complete loony and a very nasty
piece of work how did he manage to
become the chancellor of Germany in 1933
and then the rest is unfortunately all
history but those questions are
difficult questions and I think the
teaching of History I'm very passionate
about teaching history in schools in
particular I think it's the best
possible way that people can think about
scenarios and Venture Capital investing
is absolutely thinking about scenarios
and they can imagine
how something will go very badly wrong
and the whole of money is lost and they
can imagine how you can make a huge
amount of money could you speak just for
a definition of terms again so we
covered Betfair counterfactual
what does this mean it means it didn't
have to happen like it happened so a
counterfactual to the outbreak of the
first world war in 1914 would be there
was no war the Kaiser went to see his
relatives in Buckingham Palace and they
had a drink and they decided that they
they would defuse the situation and sure
the Archduke Franz Ferdinand had been
assassinated but you didn't necessarily
have to mobilize all the troops in
Europe because one guy had been bumped
off by an anarchist on and and you know
that assassination and insane as well
just a number of things that had to
happen for that to even turn off yes
exactly so so all these things were
complete freak occurrences I think Lenin
coming to power was a complete freak
that would not have happened if the
Germans and the Swiss had not given him
safe passage to Finland station in
Leningrad to what became learning
grandson Petersburg at the time and if
Lenin had not got there the
democratically elected social
revolutionary party would have been in
power and it was a middle of the road I
suppose you'd call it left-wing
capitalist political party it was a bit
like the British labor party or the
Democrats in in the US today if we take
the examination of History we put under
a microscope we see these many examples
where things didn't have to turn out the
way they turned down and there are
multiple failure points or potential
failure points
if something very tiny hadn't happened
then this very large thing would not
have been a consequence of it how do you
and if if I'm interrupting and you had
more to add beforehand please feel free
to do that but how do you then connect
that to say making a successful
investment if you could just connect
those dots okay it's really saying the
future is terribly terribly uncertain I
mean one of the great historians that
was Oxford when I was a student there
was Alan Taylor ajp Taylor a socialist
left-wing sort of guy but he was a very
very good historian he said the future
is a land of which there are no Maps
so
when you look back in history everything
seems inevitable but when you look
forward in history it's wide open and so
in thinking about an investment you
always got to say what is the most
likely thing that can happen and what
are the outlying things that could
happen
so the most likely thing for Bedford for
example was that the growth rate of 60 a
month would go down to 10 a month or
five percent a month but all you then
need to do is to run the numbers on the
implications of that would be for the
future and a more cheerful scenario and
even more cheerful scenario would be the
the growth rate was sustained for a
little bit longer and a little tiny
percent more and then you'd make a huge
amount of money another scenario would
be the government closed it down because
there was no legislation
which covered an online betting exchange
yeah that happens a lot more in Tech
than people would like to admit yep you
know they could have been closed down
and you know there's a labor government
there and thank God the labor government
was not a loonie left labor government
and you know you can just see the story
all these poor working-class people who
haven't got very much money being taken
to the cleaners by this nasty betting
exchange now are you speaking about the
the dynasty but most of it no
politicians would forget about the bit
that they don't want you to know right
but nevertheless you know it was trading
on gambling and and gambling is an
addiction it's like alcohol
etc etc so a lot of people from the left
and the right are opposed to gambling so
it could have gone wrong but then you do
an expected value calculation and you
say well if it doesn't go wrong I can
make a hundred times my money
if it does go wrong I lose all my money
let's assume that the probability of it
going wrong is more than 10 then you're
still on an expected value basis as long
as it wasn't your only investment but if
you've got a portfolio of investment
then you just go ahead and make the
investment so my next question was going
to be how you assign probabilities that
I would love to know how you think about
that because this applies not just to
investing I want to make this clear to
folks we're talking about investing
because it is a discrete explicit way of
looking at points on the scoreboard it's
a little easier
to assess success and failure right
imagine
if baseball didn't have any statistics
right it's like how would you say it was
a good player you track the numbers and
you can do that in investing as well
whereas in life if we're talking about
somebody who is quote unquote successful
but we don't have metrics it's a lot
harder but this type of thinking applies
to so much more yes of course how do you
assign probabilities how do you think
about assigning probabilities so that
you can do the expected value and if you
could run through an example just for
people who aren't familiar with that
type of simple calculation that'd be
super helpful but how do you assign the
probabilities because that seems like
well one of the toughest challenges
maybe I I look at the fish and I sort of
you know clock a number from the air now
there are people
and some of them I've employed in the
past you know who would go through a
whole series of spreadsheets in order to
try and work out but I just say what's
my best guess and then I will double the
best guess or or half the best guess and
then I've got a low case and a high case
it's very very simple do you think that
being an optimist or seeing the upside
more than you see the downside is a
liability in that case well it's a
liability unless the optimism is
Justified and and at that stage I'm
trying to be realistic and I might ask
other people who are more sane than I am
that is less optimistic to actually make
the same calculations and then I just
look at what the results of those are
but it's not rocket science
especially when you have even a few
months of data right I mean you have
something to look at it's not just an
idea on a napkin
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront there is a lot happening in
the U.S and Global economies right now a
lot that's an understatement are we in a
recession is it a bear Market what's
going to happen with inflation so many
questions so few answers I can't tell
the future nobody can but I can tell you
about a great place to earn more on your
savings and that's wealthfront
wealthfront is an app that helps you
save and invest your money right now you
can earn 4.55 apy that's the annual
percentage yield with the wealthfront
cash account that's more than 11 times
more interest than if you left your
money in a savings account at the
average Bank according to fdic.gov so
why wait earn 4.55 on your cash today
plus it's up to five million dollars in
FDIC insurance through partner Banks and
when you open an account today you'll
get an extra 50 bonus with a deposit of
500 or more there are already nearly
half a million people using wealthfront
to save more earn more and build
long-term wealth so why wait visit
wealthfront.com Tim to get started
that's wealthfront.com Tim this was a
paid endorsement by wealthfront
tonight just say that this question
about history being important I've got
another empirical justification for this
because I would bring into the court
room exhibit a which is Bill byton now
Bill Bain was the founder of boning
company which was probably the most
successful strategy consulting or
consulting firm in the world during a
1980s 1970s 1980s it was founded after
the Boston Consulting Group set up by
Bruce Henderson who was the pioneer he
was like the Charles Darwin of strategy
you know he believed in competition and
he saw basically a darwinian world of
competition and he worked out system for
that and Bruce founded the Boston
Consulting Group which I worked for for
a time they fired me so I still think
it's a wonderful wonderful company and I
think they're probably right to find me
but in that story we covered in episode
one for people who want to dig into that
I wouldn't tell the story if it hadn't
been a happy ending the happy ending
actually hinged very much on Bill bone
because when I knew that BCG were going
to fire me Tim I arranged an interview
with Bill Bain and I was very lucky to
do that because he was the head of the
company but they were looking for people
at that stage because they were growing
at 40 a year I think there's a theme in
this which is very very high growth
was a complete genius because he was a
historian he did not have an MBA he did
not have an engineering degree he did
not have a quantitative degree of any
kind he was a historian and he then met
Bruce Henderson when he was trying to
raise funds he gave up history research
he thought that was very boring and then
he got a job with his old University
in Tennessee
and his job was to raise money so since
Bruce Henderson was an alumnus of the
University bill goes to see Bruce and
Bruce refuses to give him any money to
the university but says why don't you
come to Boston because I'd like you to
meet some of my colleagues and we might
give you a job the colleagues were
totally aghast at the idea that bill
Bain should become
not just a member but quite an important
member of the Boston Consulting Group
they said this guy
is really intelligent but he's totally
unqualified he has no credentials
whatsoever and sure he's very
intelligent but lots of priests are very
intelligent we're not going to hire a
whole bunch of priests are we so I'm
sorry if I'm digressing a bit PCG
Priestly Consulting Group
Well I think that would go down quite
well actually uh holy [__] so anyway so
Bruce then hands at the end of the day
he hands these assessments that all his
senior people had made of Bill Bain all
of them giving a thumbs down to actually
hiring him and he says to Bill
Bill what do you think about what my
colleagues have said and then Bill Bain
reportedly said to Bruce Bruce Henderson
was the greatest of respect to your
colleagues they are wrong because I
understand how to make a consulting firm
very very successful and I know how to
sell to people who've got a lot of money
and chief Executives of companies
because I've raised a huge amount of
money for the University even though you
decided in your mean way and it didn't
exactly spell it out quite like this not
to do that so I'm going to be very
successful thank God that he rejected
Bill Danes plea for funds for the
University otherwise what a trajectory
then worked in the Boston consultancy
group he
was one of the co-inventors of the gross
share Matrix the cows and stars the
question marks no idea what that is this
is the greatest how can you not know
this this is the greatest demonstration
it's won my life Richard take a piece of
paper and draw a line down
the axes are the growth rate of the
market
where it's high or low below 10 or above
that and the other axis is the relative
market share so a business that is in
the top left-hand quadrant because BCG
Drew their grass backwards was high
growth but it was high relative market
share in other words in very simple
English it was the leader in its
particular Niche and my investments have
all been my successful investment has
all been in Star businesses did you
mention a cow am I making that up did
you just mention you said star well
there's some other word that you threw
cash cows
cows like how do cows fit into this okay
I just want to make sure you have to be
in the right mood yeah I just wasn't
sure what you'd slipped into my
sparkling water okay got it okay
honestly I haven't had anything to drink
so we drank a lot last night
anything today no so a cash cow is the
leader now you speak in my language I
think the cash cow is something that
throws off cash because it's low growth
and it's very profitable because it's
the market leader a star business is a
business that is in a high growth market
and therefore is going to grow much
faster and because it's the leader in
its segment it's going to be very
profitable if it isn't very profitable
already because it's going to have
either higher prices than people who are
have a lower market share because it has
less brand reputation or less popularity
or is going to have lower costs because
it's got greater scale or it's going to
be both it's like sailing across the
Atlantic and discovering that there's
you know land at the other end even it's
not the end is once it's done everyone
says we'll go to America but before it's
done it wasn't obvious it enabled BCG
and then later bone and Company to make
tens of millions of dollars
very early in the game when they weren't
very large quick question about that is
that in their selection of clients and
therefore banking on future billing or
it was using that as a way of thinking
about helping their clients exactly the
latter so in other words they go to big
Diversified companies don't forget in
the 1970s they would go to a g and be
like you need to get rid of these get
rid of this 20 divisions or whatever and
one of the things that you had to get
rid of were most of the question marks
which were very high growth very sexy
because they're in very high growth
markets like artificial intelligence
today but never having a cat in the
Hills charts and actually becoming a
market leader so what BCG said and what
boning companies said to those companies
is sell them you know get out while
they're going is good because it's a
sexy business sexy mom but you're never
going to be never going to make any
money I did get interrupted with a very
mundane question a cat's chance in hell
is that a real expression
I've heard snowball's chance in hell but
I meant to say dog oh wait I've never
heard that either poor dogs too dogs
chants in hell no that's okay I don't
want to interrupt the flow I just the
imagery is so strong and you're you're
adorable dog is right next door well of
course dogs were on the Matrix as well
but cats weren't which was catastrophic
oh
you are you are the master of the puns
I've noticed this I'm descending to
toguru don't worry about it oh boy so
this Matrix and you said they did it
backwards does that mean that something
that's going well would grow up into the
left no it was like what it meant was it
confusing the the thing which had the
greatest sales was on the left rather
than the right normally you would say if
it's bigger I mean this is something I
don't approve of at all which is that
you know we tend to think about time as
always disappearing and that if
something's bigger it's actually going
to be to the right of the graph BCG put
the bigger thing on the left
so the cash cow and the star were on the
left whereas if you logically they
should have been bigger than that other
side and I don't know some that someone
made a mistake and it just got just
trying to Harvard in you know
um it was one of the greatest charts oh
I'm not criticizing yeah it was but they
made a mistake you know yeah well you
know just think how how big it could
have been if they'd just
on the right side all right let's segue
for a second here
broadly speaking
how do you apply some of these
principles and I know we've discussed
this on some level before and you
mentioned Oxford we are going to come
back to Oxford purely out of
self-interest I have a question about
that but
what are some of the ways that you have
found most effective to apply some of
this type of thinking to your own life
or in terms of looking at in the case of
your Investments these critical few
Investments because like you said in
venture capital and in many types of
investing if you look at people who have
amassed vast sumps of wealth they
generally have high concentration and
then they in some cases diversify to
sort of protect against downside and
sustain wealth but to build it people
usually have very concentrated positions
to do that
if there is some element a skill
involved you need to know how to
separate the sort of critical few from
the trivial menu in in a sense
what are some of the most impactful ways
that you've applied that type of
thinking 80 20 principle Etc to your
your own life outside of you know
business well you supply the answer
which I was wanted to give you but the
answer is the 80 20 principle is the
link
between the investment performance and
venture capital is an extreme form of
this it's not 80 20 it's 99 1 or
something like that and network
businesses are the same thing and wealth
is the same thing you know and then just
think about Bezos or musk you know just
think how much money they've managed to
make out of essentially one investment
each which has been fantastically
successful
so the 80 20 principle runs through like
a in a stick of rock the seaside's name
is sort of you know always running
through it runs through the whole of my
thinking in terms of my own success or
money but also things like happiness I'm
trying to think what are the few things
that I need to do in order to attain
what I want what is the 20 or what is
the one percent or whatever
and I think in happiness
and I'm very very keen on talking about
happiness because I've been thinking
about this a lot recently personally and
for other people
happiness depends on very very few
things for a start there's an argument
which says that we have a baseline
happiness level and we gravitate back to
it and is this connected in some obscure
way to genetics but I've never actually
seen a good explanation of how it is
related to genetics but nevertheless it
is intuitive in a way and and people
give examples of when you get married
you're suddenly very happy or when you
fall in love you're very happy when you
get married you're still very happy a
year later you may be no more happy than
you were a year before you met Mr Right
or miss right
and so that's temporary and you revert
to your habitual Baseline happiness
level and this Baseline happiness level
also is evidenced when people win the
lottery Lottery right they have a lot of
money they spend a lot of money or have
a catastrophic accident in some cases
right yeah driving their Porsche rather
too fast but yeah the evidence actually
on on lotteries is very mixed and it
isn't as simple as people say all the
evidence if you look at it on a
subjective level of people reporting is
that people who are wealthier are
actually on average happier than people
who are poor and this is true if you
look at it in countries it's true if you
look at it within a particular country
and it's also true if you look at it in
terms of people's lives I don't know
very many people who become very rich
who are much more miserable than they
used to be or indeed not happier than
they that they were and it's often the
the pursuit of material things is
useless but what about medicine you know
what about Dentistry you know before the
20th century very few children actually
lasted Beyond five years
and as a result of medicine improving
immensely and also hygiene improving
immensely
that's down to a negligible level
imagine the trauma for a mother or a
father you know in seeing three or four
of their children die before the age of
five that's a huge amount of human
suffering and that's removed people
forget about that Dentistry you know
when I was growing up a visit to the
dentist was a cause for great
trepidation and I remember the dentist
having this drill as it almost Daughtry
in my small mouth when I was about nine
years old and it just made such a
horrible noise that you just knew it was
going to be painful even if it wasn't
particularly painful nowadays you don't
get that Dentistry has improved
immensely and Dentistry actually also
affects lifespan and you look also at
the fact that unless people get cancer
these days they're likely to last much
longer than they would have done a
generation ago much longer you know
maybe depending on the country might be
the average length of life might have
been 50 years about not that long ago
you know 30 or 40 years ago and now it's
80. now what does that mean well it not
only means that people can live longer
and healthier lives than they used to
live but it also means that there are a
few bereaved people and that also is an
enormous cause of pain and suffering how
do we jump from the macro the sort of
societal National level to the personal
so for yourself you said very few things
really matter when it comes to happiness
and just for not to beat a dead horse
but this is kind of my role how would
you define or think about happiness just
so we are all on the same page as to
what that means to you is it just a
general sense of well-being yes I mean
well the way that sociologists and
psychologists do that is they ask people
to write their happiness on a one to ten
scale
and they interpret the results it's a
subjective writing and a lot of people
say well people don't really know
whether they're happy or not or they
pretend to be happy when they're not
happy I just don't believe that I think
that people generally do know how happy
they are and when they give you a racing
they are giving you an honest rating but
if you ask people have you actually
deviated significantly from what you say
now you say eight okay so that's pretty
good very good today was it true that
you were always in a range of six to ten
I mean that's something that for example
you Val Noah Harari who I know you've
interviewed says that there's a little
bit of leeway there but there's not a
hell of a lot leeway but have you ever
met someone who's had a really miserable
childhood and then when they left home
I've actually enjoyed life a lot I've
met I have many people for sure that
shouldn't be the case if the Baseline
level is correct but the argument goes
much beyond that which is to say even if
it was correct you don't have to assume
that it's immutable you don't have to
assume it cannot be changed and if you
want to be happier there are various
ways of doing it again one of the best
documented findings of sociology is that
people who are married are happier than
people who are not married now of course
there's no worse than an unhappy
marriage or partnership I make no
distinction at all between a long-term
relationship and a marriage because not
everyone gets married these days but
it's a very good bet to be married
rather than to be single throughout your
life so but coming back to 80 20 that's
one thing that you can do which is to
make sure that you have a long-term
relationship with someone preferably
someone that you really like it's going
to make a huge amount of difference and
there are various other subsidiary
things for example I think it's very
important if you're from a purely
selfish point of view if you want to be
happy you want to be in a relationship
with someone who's very happy for
themselves yeah which makes a huge
amount of difference you know there's
some people are just incredibly
difficult to live with because they're
miserable it also you know all the
research shows that there's a guy who's
got a love lab called Dawn gottman I
think he's in Chicago yeah there are
very few indicators of whether people
are going to get divorced or whether
they're going to have a happy long-term
relationship one of them is that they're
friends they actually like each other
well that's a blinding glimpse of the
audiences and but how many married
people do you know who actually really
don't have the same interests or they
don't share the same Past Times in any
regard
they might have different values but
they're married you know well that's a
pretty dumb thing to do so the first
thing to do is make sure that you have a
successful long-term relationship and if
you do that you're going to be pretty
happy the second thing that you must do
according to all the research is you've
got to love your job
now many people don't love their jobs
and one of the reasons that they don't
love their jobs is because they're doing
it for money now I think money is
wonderful I think money can help to make
you happier but if to earn a lot of
money you have to work for a boss who's
an ogre or you know just not very nice
or inconsiderate or makes you work very
very long hours and you know it doesn't
really care about your welfare you're
going to be much more miserable when
working for a boss who's relatively
relaxed cheerful happy person themselves
but how many people don't like their
boss it's ridiculous absolutely you
should resign or you should have
poisoned the boss or bump them off you
know absolutely so you know that's a
very a very very simple killing of the
boss but
sorry no liabilities it's what I said
it's not what he said and we don't like
lawyers anyway so go send your lawyers
letters to gambits yeah please
I'll be back
anyway you get the picture and then you
know one of the things that I say in the
80 20 book which you very kindly helped
say is worth reading from people in the
80s 2020 principle is that why don't you
spend more time on the things that you
like so a lot of people say well
Pleasures you know this is not very
spiritual you know people like Pleasures
would you rather spend an evening with
people that you enjoy spending an
evening with or would you rather spend
an evening with people that are
miserable I think the former yeah and
it's amazing I go around asking people
who are your best five friends in the
world and people come up with a list and
then I say who are the five people that
you spend most time with and very often
the lists are completely different and
that tells you that that person they
might be happy but they're certainly
going against the grave they're
handicapping it yeah and again people
you know some people like living where
they live other people find it noisy and
unpleasant other people find it too
boring why don't you go and live
somewhere that you actually really like
that suits you that has the same sort of
people that you enjoy seeing in the
street why don't you do that most people
just doesn't cross their mind I think in
America it's one of the redeeming
features of America is if people do move
around a lot but we're talking in
Portugal and the indigenous Portuguese
they don't move there are a relatively
few number of things that you do and of
course you have to read one of my books
to find out what they are but they're
absolutely obvious well hold on we'll
get plenty of people to read the books
because I recommend the books and I
actually give I mean I gave you some
wording you know some writing to use
when you launch the revised edition of
the 80 20 principle which I never do
because I had a huge impact on my life
but not to
over tease people when you are working
with or talking to friends or
others about happiness what are some of
the questions that you ask them like the
five
who are your closest Five friends who do
you spend the most time with and
incongruity there it goes a bit beyond
1920 I'm now writing a book called 80 20
beliefs
and in order to do that I've interviewed
50 people that I know very well and who
I trust to tell me the truth and they
trust to tell me some of the uh intimate
things about their life particularly
what went wrong
and I asked them two questions very
simple questions one is is there any
belief that has really made a big
difference in your life is that at any
stage you have changed
so you used to believe X and now you
believe why
and ninety percent of the people nine
out of ten as people know it's a very
small sample but it's an extraordinary
coincidence if they're all saying this
and it's not quite true generally say
that they have at some stage changed an
important belief and a belief I'm not
talking about something which is an
academic belief you know where you might
believe that one politician is better
than another or you might believe in
green values or we might not I'm talking
about belief that has made a big
difference in your own life
and why has it made a big difference in
your own life well it's because you've
acted in a certain way and that's
generated certain results
so I asked people what belief have you
changed and very often that in fact
almost invariably triggers a saying that
I actually believed something which was
not in my own interests and I call that
a toxic belief
for example a friend of mine who's about
60 years old she looks a lot younger
we'll call her Sally showings Sally had
quite a nice life
she moved from England which is you know
it's cold and rainy and horrible to
South Africa which as you know is sunny
and very nice to Cape Town actually
which is the nicest place in South
Africa unless you happen want to track
wild animals it's good for almost
everything else got wonderful beaches
got mountains it's got very nice food
and it's quite cheap as well so you know
it's a good idea to go to Cape Town if
you if you want it's slightly dangerous
now so but that's another matter anyway
she had a very nice life until the last
five years and in the last five years
catastrophe struck her husband
was diagnosed in the very early stages
of having Alzheimer's disease
and he decided that in order to give his
wife Sally a chance he would commit
suicide obviously you know an awful
thing and Trauma you know for for her as
well
and then shortly after that happened
covert happened and covered you know
there are many hard luck stories about
covid but but the one which uh Sally
tells is that she had two dogs and the
dogs were very important uh you know and
particularly important after her husband
was gone
and she in in the covert regime in South
Africa she wasn't allowed to take the
dogs out at any stage of the 24 hours of
the day without risking
imprisonment and having the dogs shot in
other words you couldn't take them out
to do their business or anything like
that you couldn't take them out for any
exercise and if the police stopped you
they would quite likely shoot the dogs
and put you in prison so she decided
that this was not a very nice Society to
live in any longer she loved living in
South Africa but then she decided to to
do something about it the point is for
the first 55 years of her life she'd
followed the lead of her husband and
other people she'd Gone With the Flow
the way that she explained it to me was
saying I believe Que Sera Sera whatever
will be will be the future's not ours to
see Que Sera Sera so in order she
trusted to fate and fate was very good
to her when her husband had gone and
when the covered regime in South Africa
was so unpleasant she decided that she
could no longer go with the flow and she
took a very brave decision that she
would Up Sticks seller house in Cape
Town and come and live as it happens in
Portugal and that has been enormously
successful it's it is absolutely to come
back to my earlier theme it's
transformed her happiness
by pure chance she's met a guy that
she's getting married to now
they are very happy together and she's
very you know you can see that her eyes
line up she's really really happy three
or four years ago she was in the depths
of depression and sort of you know she
was wondering whether she should follow
her husband in terms of committing
suicide so it is possible if you take
charge to actually do something and
that's why I hate this concept of the
Baseline happiness level because Mark
said philosophers have tried to describe
the world the point is to change it and
similarly your happiness levels you know
you it's no use them telling you about
the Baseline happiness level and saying
well they don't say it but they almost
imply it but it's inevitable and you
can't transcend that so if you're on H
you're stuck between six and ten
depending on the weather and
circumstances and whether good things
have happened to you that day or
whatever but you know you can't go down
to a three or if you're a three you
can't go up to a ten
but there are many cases that I know
where people have actually transformed
themselves you know I know someone who
was incredibly miserable for a very long
time and why was he miserable this
person was miserable because he grew up
in a very well-off upper middle class
family he said he was born with a silver
spoon in his mouth
and he expected that life would carry on
in being easy and of course when he left
home and had to earn a living he
discovered that actually things were
very difficult now things were not quite
as difficult as he imagined they were I
mean for example he started a very very
successful business and he ran that
business for six years and made a lot of
money from selling it so when I was
talking to this chap who I'll call
Alexander Alexander I said you must have
got a degree of self-confidence and Good
Feeling from your experience in starting
and running and selling this business
and he said to me you must be joking
those six years were years of high
anxiety I was constantly firefighting it
seemed so difficult to me it seems so
difficult
and I said to him well you know it
didn't seem difficult observing it and
he said well actually it's because I
expected things to be easy and you
remember M Scott Peck wrote a book which
starts life is difficult
this is one of the great things about
life if you understand this you can
transcend it because you anticipate that
things are going to be difficult and you
can take pride in sort of you know
overcoming difficulties but if you
expect there are going to be no
difficulties obviously you're going to
be disillusioned and so paradoxically
this miserable sounding philosophy which
says life is difficult is actually a
wonderful philosophy because it means
that you can take pride in getting over
difficulties but when you're confronted
with difficulties what you do is like
Alexander and say it's too difficult it
shouldn't be this difficult
then obviously you're going to be
miserable despite objectively
having a great success yeah it makes me
think of and I wish I had the
attribution but happiness equals reality
minus expectations in a sense and this
is also very reminiscent of Marcus
Aurelius and meditations of course but
how did Alexander if he did make the
switch did he make the switch he did
make the switch but it took him about 20
years and he said from the time because
he started business when he was in his
early 30s and from being aged 40 onwards
then he got into a pretty dark place at
one stage and then he started going to
12 steps meetings where people sit
around and say you know I've had these
difficulties I've reconstructed my life
and I'm on the path to recovery he also
took some therapy and he also reflected
on why he was miserable and he did
realize it was miserable because he
expected life to be easy and it wasn't
very often having the insight into what
a toxic belief is is the first step to
actually being able to overcome it very
often we don't realize what toxic
beliefs we have and therefore we suffer
from them I mean in my own case I had a
pathological need to be successful
and when I was in my early 20s as I
recounted I got employed by the Boston
Consulting Group which was wonderful I
loved the company I still think it's a
great company I still think the people
in a very interesting intellectually
very interesting as well and the whole
thing you know it was great except for
the fact they didn't like me very much
so you know that was a bit of a bit of a
problem I suffered I mean I know that
this sounds ridiculous but I really
suffered in my soul for two or three
years being miserable because I wasn't
successful
successful meaning financially
successful but not only is financially
successful I wanted to please accept by
the colleagues and this was my first
serious job I hadn't been successful in
my two previous jobs either but there
were good reasons for that at least when
I could rationalize some I worked for
shell and it was a terrible company to
work for because it was very
bureaucratic and people were thinking
about how much they were going to make
when they retired and could they retire
at 50 rather than at 65. so that you
know a risk of getting a ridiculous
company and then I worked for another
company which was much much better but I
wasn't particularly successful at that
either so it was very important to me
that I got good credentials I got a good
business school degree I got a good
degree from Oxford I knew I was
intelligent and actually I was able to
make quite a lot of money even in BCG
because they had a system of billability
which said you get paid according to how
many hours you Bill and I made sure that
I built a lot of hours and I had various
strategies for for doing it but I
couldn't do what the BCG people really
admired which was heavy duty financial
and market analysis I'm actually I think
dyslexic with numbers I'm not very good
at mental arithmetic I'm very good you
didn't have the fish pond then you
needed yeah
anyway so may I pause so don't I want to
bookmark for a second but I can't let
this go because this is just how I am
I'm like [__] with an apple core some
inside baseball
Richard's lab loves apple cores
the ways for billing hours successfully
what were some of your your ways for
billing hours successfully well I made
sure that I had some clients that liked
me it's always helpful and I did a lot
of work which was solitary in other
words the case team was me and maybe a
junior assistant
and I was actually quite good at selling
business as long as they weren't looking
to be wild in terms of heavy duty
analysis and I'm quite intuitive you
know so I I could come up with what the
company should do and they quite liked
that but my colleagues didn't like that
and the more successful I was at selling
business the more they frowned on it
because you said you know you're not
using a proper case team you're not
doing at the BCG way where's the heavy
duty financial analysis where's the
final presidency
and sort of you know Road to Damascus
stuff and there's a vision you know you
prove that black is white and they're
investing in all the wrong things and
they're stupid whereas I wouldn't I
wouldn't go along to his clients and say
you're stupid I would say you know
you're very clever because you're doing
this and you know what this that and the
other was what I wanted them to do not
what they really were doing so I used a
little bit of Elementary Common Sense
and psychology so yeah I had some
clients who really liked me but you were
unfitting there I didn't fit the
template but my point is yeah you're
pathologically addicted pathological
beliefs I had to be successful at BCG
right right that was stupid yeah stupid
you know and then afterwards I thought
well am I not suited to strategy
Consulting I said yes I am extremely
decision because I understand the
concepts very well I can actually work
out what people should do and not bad at
emotional intelligence and so
why don't I give it a go at another firm
so I went along to talk to McKinsey they
rejected me so that was fine and then I
managed to weasel away to go and see
Bill Bain now this is where it gets very
interesting for me at least
because I had this appointment with Bill
bone to get there I got through the
London office who were very desperately
short of people so they thought that I
would do and they sent me off to see
Bill Bain
and that was so lucky for me because
bilboam was actually his story I didn't
know this at the time and so he said
what was your undergraduate degree and I
said history and we had a 20-minute
conversation about history of
counterfactual stuff
and he obviously enjoyed that but I said
to him Mr Bain I really want to know why
it is that your company is growing
faster than the Boston's Consulting crew
and I really want to understand if there
is a Formula behind it what the formula
is and this was music to Bill's ears
because what he'd done was work out a
way of having a relationship long-term
relationship with a client BCG would
work for anyone been in company again is
80 20 consistent would only work for the
top dog the chief executive in a large
company and they wouldn't work for the
head of a country they wouldn't work for
the head of marketing or anything like
that and they would again like me on the
fish pond they would then say how big
could this be in other words we don't
want to continually be churning clients
am I right in saying that they also
folded into that had the some type of
requirement that they would offer sort
of category exclusivity or yes not work
with I will not work with you client
your competitors but in exchange I ask
and what would they ask if I'd ask that
you don't work without competitors in
fact they put it around more bluntly
than that and said we won't work for
your competitors and you won't work for
hours
and the Infantry of this you know it was
breathtaking and and of course they did
it quite smoothly you know bill was a
great salesman he didn't actually want
to sell business he as soon as possible
he managed to delegate that to other
people but it was incredible he was
saying we have got something really
valuable to offer they believed in the
formula they believed in the gross share
Matrix even though it involves shooting
dogs but but you know they it was like
Evangelical you know and people compared
to the baners to the Moon is and they
talked about Bane it's interesting there
was a lot of truth behind that because
they were fanatical and the most
important thing in the performance
appraisal was attitude and when I heard
that I thought this is ridiculous this
is just brainwashing but actually I came
to believe that it was true that all of
the people in Boeing Company were on the
same side in BCG there were factions you
know there was a faction which was the
English people thinking that they were
smarter than the Americans for example
and as the intellectual faction than
there was the banking faction you know
basically it was like a mosaic and a lot
of energy was being generated but it was
at Cross purposes so in bowling company
there might be less intellectual
Firepower but there was more energy
because everyone was working in the same
way how did they assess attitude do you
remember yeah they sent you to charm
school
and if you didn't if you didn't pass
through the charms well hold on all that
all right so elaborate on what this
means I'm guessing you're not you know
practicing walking with a book on your
head and arranging silverware what were
you what were you doing
they didn't send me to Charm School I
was too seniors
yeah I think they took that box
erroneously but never mind so what
happened in that interview was that bill
bone and I got on like a house on fire
he enjoyed the interview he went and got
one of the top five people in the
company beneath him a guy called Ralph
Willard who was big fat man but
enormously cheerful and enormously
optimistic and can do sort of person and
also a very clever man and a very nice
man I say that because he liked me a lot
but Bill Bain said to him you know I've
had this great chat with Richard and I
think we want to hire you don't do that
it undercuts your bargaining power and
or restaurant so he said to Ralph you
know will you talk to Richard and work
out how much we're going to pay him and
then of course that was an invitation to
me to tell them how much I was earning a
lot of money at the Boston Consulting
Group and Ralph looked at me and said
you may be very good Richard but you're
very expensive
anyway and I became a partner in boning
company in record time I remember there
were people in Boston Consulting Group
who when I was fired as a consultant
were managers and they want to become
vice president which was equivalent to a
partner in boating company I became a
partner from being a consultant within a
year and that was faster than these
people in BCG could get promoted to the
vice president for a manager so they
couldn't understand this at all and the
truth is that bilbane decided there and
then that I could be a partner of his so
of course I liked working at bank but
you had to step outside of the maybe
implicit constraint that you would have
applied to yourself which was I need to
be successful within BC BCG yeah so it
was good enough to be successful within
Bank the reason that I was asking all
these questions though Tim was that from
a very beginning from the very first
week that I'd been in BCG I knew that I
wanted to start a strategy consulting
firm why did I want to start strategy
consoling firm because they made a lot
of money and one of the things that I
had had as an ambition from nine years
old was To Be A Millionaire but I saw
strategy Consulting and being part owner
of the strategy consulting firm having
seen or imagined anyway how much money
buying and Company was making most of
which ended up in Bill Bane's pocket
I wanted to be the owner of the strategy
consulting firm so I was asking Bill
what the formula was out of visceral
interest and you know he thought well
Richard really wants to understand the
Bain way of doing things that wasn't
true I did want to understand it but I
didn't want to understand it because I
wanted a 15-year career impacting
company
what did he say
in terms of formula well now he
explained the relationship the whole
thing you know he explained the speech
that he would give to the chief
Executives you know we won't work for
your competitors you won't work for
hours and the he had various things but
one of the other dictator that he had
was to say to them we are going to make
a lot of money for you your profits are
going to go up but we don't want you to
refuse
place any arbitrary limit on our budgets
so if we recommend at the end of the
study which has been very successful
that we do something else you are going
to say yes
basically it's a partnership we're going
to make you a lot of money you're going
to make us a lot of money and Bill Bain
was this is another thing about being a
historian wrong a business person or an
MBA
he wasn't really fascinated by the nuts
and bolts of Consulting
he was really interested in making money
and he recognized that this was highly
levered because the companies that he
was working for were very big companies
and they were quoted on the stock market
so you knew what the value was of
getting a certain increase in profits
and increase in the growth rate revenues
and profits and so it was very easy to
see like me sitting on the fish pond and
thinking about Betfair that this was a
formula for making an extraordinary
amount of money and he later capped that
by going into the private Equity
business and helping those companies
that they invested in make a lot more
money so they did the same sort of
analysis as being capital or yeah
Capital yeah exactly and Bain Capital
made more money
actually including for most of the early
main partners because they put money
into it which then became enormously
valuable so anyway that so Bill Bain
is exhibit
a in terms of proving that historians
can make money and not only that it goes
deeper than that which is like Bruce
Henderson Bill Bain stopped Consulting
as soon as he possibly could there is a
lovely story about this which I don't
think I put none in my books but the
lovely story was that he would be asked
by a new client to go and work on a case
and in the early days it was quite
difficult to refuse if it was done in
Pratt Street or Baxter travenor Bill
Bain going to say no I'm not going to
work on this assignment I want to have
an easy life I don't want to do
Consulting so what it would do is go
along with Ralph Willard to see the
chief executive at the beginning of an
assignment the chief executive has asked
that bill Boone actually works on the
assignment Bill didn't say yes but but
he arranged a meeting with the chief
executive and Ralph Willard and himself
and they would get in and they they
would have some pleasantries he would
talk about sport you know last night's
baseball match or whatever and he would
research whether the chief executive was
interested in that particular sport
anyway they'd talk about that for five
minutes
and then bulban would then stand up he'd
stand up
and say to the chief executive
I'm sorry but I've got to go now and the
reason I've got to go is I want to leave
you with Ralph you're like Ralph Ralph
is really good Ralph is better than me
and then he'll stand up and walk away
and go back to Boston so the startled
chief executive would then do something
that turns around and say are you better
than Bill Bain
and Ralph would say something this is
all worked out in advance Ralph would
say well Bill certainly thinks so and I
happen to think that his judgment is
very good but collapse in laughter and
the chemistry would be assured from that
point genius I must tell you this
because the thing that was quite
extraordinary about Bill was he worked
out how to run a consulting firm without
doing any work or doing probably about
two days work a month and and the way
that he did that apart from extreme
delegation was that he had a monthly
worldwide Partners meeting
and all of the partners had to attend
now I thought it was nonsense to go from
London to Boston for a one-day meeting
and so I didn't turn up for the first
day of the the first drinks in the
evening
and one of my colleagues who was later
to be uh partnered with me in in lak Ian
Evans was whispering on the phone he was
saying you've got to get here you've got
to get to Boston but it was furious and
I said no I got a client emergency I
don't want to go to Boston anyway you
know I don't want to fly it's ridiculous
flying overnight and I don't like
flights he said you've got to get here
so when I turn up Bill makes a beeline
for me and I say to myself this is great
Bill think something important and he
said to me Richard did you did you not
know that we were starting the partners
meeting this evening with drinks and
dinner and I said yes I had a client
emergency Bill and he said I was
beginning to stutter at this point and
he said Richard I wanted to be clear
when we have a partner's meeting you
have got to be here or you will no
longer be a partner and then and then
he smiled and said welcome and have a
drink
so that was that was how he was like he
had red lines you know basically all
Partners had to be there at the part of
me not only that but what they had to do
was to say on the clients that they were
responsible for how much revenue they
made in the previous months how much
revenue they're going to make in each of
the next three months they did that in
front of everyone let's guess of course
yeah public humiliation or public
Applause yeah exactly and people would
actually they break into Applause and
someone
was going up you know that wasn't one
thing that bill was concerned about you
know if it been Bruce for us not Bruce
would never have a partner's meeting you
know he didn't see the point of that to
him it was all a matter of Concepts and
he wasn't really interested in the
revenues if they were good enough and to
continue opening offices and Swan around
the world and sort of you know basically
terrorize the consultants in a different
office then Bruce was was happy Bruce
was not a very nice human being although
he was a genius a global Campaign Of
Terror from Branch to Branch it was so
bad that demotivating people that all
the people Underneath Him eventually
said to him look Bruce this is not
working people would go to scientillis
who was the head of the London office
when I when I was there and say do you
know what he did to me and actually so I
mentioned this during the memorial
service for Bruce Henderson she died and
he said Psy was very dry sense of humor
he said it was not necessary to ask who
they were talking about
you know I mean I used to joke about it
I said if you hear that Bruce is on his
way jump out through the windows Escape
so let's come back to
toxic beliefs I imagine I've been
thinking about this myself for my my own
history and there are certainly examples
but some of them that I've then changed
I mean there's a recency bias here it
would be for instance I could never
re-engage with art the way I thought
that I did or the way that I did when I
was younger and I have it's only been in
the last month and there are reasons for
that but it has led to such an uptick in
my general sense of well-being and
happiness that it's head spinning it's
really
unbelievable how much of a difference
it's made I mean it was an integral part
of my entire life for so long and then I
just let it go because I was time to
grow up and be an adult and focus on
Career Etc but for people who are
listening and they're thinking to
themselves I'm sure I have disabling
beliefs but it's kind of like a visual
blind spot we all have a visual blind
spot most people I would say sure most
people listening are probably not even
aware that there is a visual blind spot
and then they certainly given that
that's the case even if they do know
they don't spend a lot of time thinking
about it
how do you find your own
toxic belief or is there a
common set of candidates are there
certain common toxic beliefs yeah there
are there are such as what will be will
be as a common toxic belief another
toxic belief is that life should be easy
another toxic belief would be that it
was absolutely essential
like me to make money or to be
successful in this particular job that
would be a toxic belief another toxic
belief was very widespread is if the
organization tells me to do something or
to move to a job that I don't really
want it will be a black mark against me
to not actually take that promotion and
I remember two people were teachers and
they both had the experience of being
asked to do something which was an
administrative matter and they both did
it and they both hated it one of them
was to be head of year nor head of year
means is you're responsible for
discipline and what that means is that
if a kid's ignore to you go and talk to
their parents and you can imagine that's
not a particularly Pleasant job it's
always sort of you know following up on
a problem and teachers like teaching
believe it or not you know that's the
whole point and so they said I love
teaching in the classroom but having a
particular person I'm thinking having
done this head of year thing for six
months I I decided that it was very
stressful and I didn't want to continue
doing it but I thought that I had to do
it and I talked to this is to come back
to your question this is one of the ways
of doing it is talk to a friend she said
you know I talked to my brother about
this and he said
nonsense you know they they won't fire
you and it won't be a black mark if you
tell them that you don't want to do this
because nobody wants to do it and so she
went to the Headmaster and said you know
exactly that and he said okay yeah yeah
we could see that you weren't happy in
that carry on and far from it being a
black mark against her the next year she
was promoted to head of English
so we build up this picture in our mind
that the organizations are much more
ogre-ish and sometimes the boss is much
more of an ogre then they really like
sometimes they are an ogre of course but
very often they're not and the
organization is more realistic than the
individual but there's often the sense
that people who have an overdose of the
what I call the Protestant work ethic
think you can't disagree with the boss
you can't disagree with the organization
and that's another very common toxic
belief and in the book 80 20 beliefs I
will list about a dozen which I think
Encompass the great majority of toxic
beliefs but there's one way of dealing
with this which is to get a friend go
out have a meal have a few drinks
perhaps and sit down and then hand them
a list of toxic beliefs and say I think
I might be suffering from a toxic belief
which one do you think it is
and of course they'll zoom in on the one
which is obvious it's always easier to
spot someone else's toxic belief than it
is to spot your own and then you swap
and you return the favor and you say
yeah that's probably right but let's
have another round of schnapps you know
Bill I've been meaning to tell you
I'm gonna help you out here this
approach of peer review is so incredibly
valuable and I have multiple cases
throughout my life of going through this
exercise in one capacity or another not
necessarily with toxic beliefs but I
read a book ages ago in high school
actually called mental toughness
training for sports
and it completely changed my life and
experience at the time which I don't say
lightly but it provided you with
effectively various criteria qualities
let's say and then you're ranked from
one to ten or something like that and
the recommendation in the book was take
this page
make copies give it to five people who
know you really well could be coaches
teachers they don't necessarily have to
be peers in the sense of other students
in my case and have them rank you from
one to ten in these various categories
and then for anything say less than a
five here's your next action and it was
remarkable to me how the Divergence
between how self-aware I thought I was
and how completely blind I was to
certain weaknesses and that informs
every step I took after that with
wrestling specifically and I went from
being at best middle of the pack
probably let's just say lower 30 in
terms of technicality and performance to
being probably for a period of time the
best wrestler on the team for that
subsequent season it was remarkable how
quickly
change could take place even with
long-standing beliefs or behaviors like
the change doesn't have to at least in
my personal experience it doesn't have
to take a long time no it doesn't I mean
I actually categorize the 50 people
40 of them said they had a toxic belief
how long did it take for them to realize
the toxic belief existed and how long
did it take to actually change the
belief into a more positive belief
and it was remarkable Tim that in nearly
all cases once someone had actually
recognized the belief once they rumbled
it as it were then it was very easy if
people didn't Rumble say rumble Rumble
Rumble is a great English expression it
means when they've discovered it they've
flushed it out I'm gonna use that and
confuse the [__] out of all my American
friends
so once they'd realized if you like no I
like Rumble Rumble okay once they've
rumbled the belief then it's easy to get
rid of it but if they didn't then they
could carry on for 20 years
and then they might go through a lot of
therapy they might go you know and
gradually Discover it but there's
another method which I have discovered
is very effective which is if someone is
suddenly or at least in the next last
six months or last year much unhappier
than they used to be and particularly if
they suffering stress
then there's a toxic belief
lurking there which needs to be rumbled
you don't automatically jump to knowing
what the toxic belief is but if you say
actually
great unhappiness or great stress is a
signal that there is a toxic belief now
let's try and work out which one it is
so I actually had a slight disagreement
with my agent about this guy sent her an
early draft of the book and she said
well you know I'm not convinced it's as
easy as you say it's a change a toxic
belief and I said well actually you're
right about that my dear agent you're
absolutely right about that but that's
because they don't realize that they've
got it and once they realize that
they've got it then it is remarkably
easy because no one wants to be unhappy
and stressed if they understand the
cause of it obviously and too often we
actually think things which are not in
our interests their ideas which have
been implanted in Us by our parents by
our teachers by our schoolmates by our
friends or they're in the general
culture that we actually must do
something and one of the things that is
my particular bug there is working hard
you know people think there's some
virtue in working hard and of course
working hard you know some people like
working hard but beyond a certain point
it becomes counterproductive and it's
always because
they were brought up that way you know
we used to think that if you were a
decent human being trying hard to be
good and arrested you had to work hard
it was part of the package but there are
so many examples of people who don't
work hard who make a much greater
contribution like Bill Bane or Bruce
Anderson despite having a Charmed Life
once they've
somehow come to a major Insight which
can have huge consequences and you don't
need to work hard when I was working at
the Boston Consulting Group 70 or 80
hours a week I was failing
the longer I work the worse it got and
the worse the stress got to the point
where you know I was thinking of
throwing up work altogether they are
related to each other is there an
opposite to the toxic belief into the
Yang yeah I guess it's not quite yet
there's a minor opposite and the major
opposite so the minor opposite although
very important is what I call good
beliefs
so I then asked my second question of
people do you remember the first
question was have you changed an
important belief in your life which I
don't Define it as a toxic blue because
I said it could be good or it could be
bad but it always turns out to be bad
and then my second question is well tell
me about the three or four beliefs that
have made a difference in your life
where you've actually acted upon those
beliefs and which two or three or four
beliefs or maybe only one belief do you
actually believe has that actually been
a good belief from that point of view it
has good consequences for you and for
other people then you get another list
of about 10 for example some people say
I follow my conscience which sounds very
sort of goody goody and all rested but
actually is psychologically makes a lot
of sense because if you follow your
conscience you can make a decision and
you always feel good about yourself from
that point of view other beliefs which
are very useful are Karma you know
belief that what goes around comes
around and sooner or later if you're a
bastard it will catch you out you know
people will stop inviting you to dinner
or they'll they'll say nasty things
about you or whatever people's
reputations are very important and
particularly in business but in any walk
of I think in any Walk of Life actually
people who are disrespectful or don't
behave well eventually get found out in
some way or another so calm is another
one kindness just the idea of kindness
there's a particularly popular amongst
women I have to say in my sample very
small sample probably not statistically
significant but a lot of women almost
half of the women mentioned kindness and
I knew because I knew the people that
they were kind people they weren't just
saying that Pro former what was the
belief that sort of kindness is a virtue
or yeah
very often the fact that the children he
said my mother said I particularly
praise my children when they've been
kind to other children so it's kind of a
double whammy from that point of view
but it's you know you go out of your way
to make life a little more comfortable
for people that you can see are
suffering and I think you know despite
sounding a bit sexist I think women
generally are more attuned to that than
I agree with this man oh other beliefs
which are important
one of the things which I found very
very interesting was that most of the
people who were apparently happiest and
I believe were happiest had either a
religious belief or a philosophical
belief which made sense to the world it
might be a belief in Evolution for
example totally contrary to what most
people think it should be a religious
belief but if people really did
believe that there was some logic to
life whether or not it might mean that
there was no logic but anyway something
explained everything Evolution's very
good at that because people can explain
almost anything by Evolution usually
flaciously in my view or if people have
a religious belief it didn't matter if
they were Buddhists or fundamentalist
Christians it didn't really matter
whether the belief was intellectually
respectable or not if people really
believed it then it was quite effective
in terms of the actions that people took
and you don't have to do the right thing
for the right reason you can do the
right thing for the wrong reason
and so the people who were less happy
didn't have any strong religious or
philosophical they didn't have any
scaffolding for you exactly yeah making
meaning of reality in some sense one of
the other beliefs which was very
important was optimism people who were
optimistic were happier and more
productive than people who were not
and books have been written about how
you can actually become more optimistic
it's not something which is immutable
there are ways of becoming more
optimistic
these are the minor opposites to the
toxic beliefs yes
some of them not quite so minor right so
good beliefs the toxic beliefs good
beliefs and what else do you think there
are on top of that I mean it's got to be
better than good
yeah they might be great but I'd turn
them Grand because the problem with
grand beliefs is that they are Grand and
they may be grandiose as well as Grand
so they're not necessarily good and when
they're not good they're extremely bad
but they are beliefs which are almost
Messianic very interesting thing this
of my 50 people eight of them had
actually a belief which they got when
they were very young usually before they
were teenagers which was completely
unfounded and completely implausible so
in my own case it was that I would
become a millionaire and you're a nine
extrapolation very rich completely I
mean I think I've described before how
that happened but it was a complete
accident but once I got the belief I
started thinking what would I need to do
in order to become a millionaire so one
of the things that I did was start a
stamp company company collecting postage
stamps and it was a wildly successful
but it did teach me a few things and we
did make a little bit of money and then
I was always looking for ways to make
money again related to stamps when
there's a Commemorative Issue an event
happens like England winning the World
Cup as as happened in 1966 when I was
16. they over stamped the existing
stamps with England winners so it was
kind of like almost like a toy printing
out it and those stamps went on sale at
the post office you can imagine everyone
wanted to win the stems and they were
sold out in most post offices throughout
the day and what I did was I get on my
bicycle and I went to every single post
office in Windsor and tried to buy as
many of these stamps and some people
would refuse to sell me any some people
would say you can have three other
people would give me whole sheets of
things as long as I could pay for them
and those became immensely valuable now
it made me a few thousand pounds but you
know it all helped and it was looking
for opportunities like that that made a
big difference what are some other
examples of grand beliefs a very common
one is I want to be prime minister or
president now you might smile at that
and say that's completely unrealistic
there were two people in my sample one
set I want to become Prime Minister this
person is now a cabinet minister if I
hadn't had that belief although it's
very unrealistic probably he won't
become Prime Minister but you never know
he's got a chance of becoming he's got a
lot closer to it than most people would
they another person's Grand belief was
that they would play a prominent role in
politics without defining what do that
person's ahead of probably the most
respected London think tank at the
present time so he gives you a focus and
it gives you an ambition and you're
sensitized to try and find those
opportunities yeah creates a selective
attention yeah another person had the
belief that they would find a cure for
cancer
now it hasn't happened yet but this
person is making considerable progress
on that and I think there's a 50 50
chance that in your lifetime if not in
mine he will actually do that it's
extraordinary for someone who was not a
scientist who was just an engineer he's
now going to Scientific conventions and
talking to people about about that so
it's a grand belief Hitler's Grand
belief was that the Jews should be wiped
out so you know the grand belief is not
necessarily a good thing and you know
that was quite a commonplace belief in
Vienna when he grew up are there other
positive historical examples of this
that stand out here well Winston
Churchill is the opposite of Hitler his
belief was stop Hitler
and
I don't know if you've gone into the
career details of Winston Churchill but
he was incredibly unsuccessful he
actually was a cabinet minister very
early on in his life but he messed
everything up hugely he was responsible
for several hundreds of thousands of
people dying in the Dardanelles in the
first world war he was responsible for
taking Britain onto the gold standard at
a completely unrealistically High
exchange rate against the US dollar in
1925. he was opposed to a very minor
measure of self-government in India in
the 1930s he lost all credibility with
his senior colleagues he got thrown out
of the cabinet he was in the wilderness
completely in the 1930s and the only
thing that saved Churchill's career was
Hitler because he was an extreme Patria
he thought the British Empire was the
best thing on on Earth he'd grown up in
a
environment and in a school Harrow where
they sang songs about Queen Elizabeth
the first defeating the Armada so you
can see that given a conditioning like
that if someone like Hitler comes along
he thinks well possibly this is a threat
to the British Empire and I've got to do
something about it there's a fascinating
story in one of the biographers by
Andrew Roberts the most recent biography
of Churchill when he was 16 years old
and this is well documented he told a
friend that there was going to be a
future terrible War he didn't give any
dates or anything like that but he said
during this war I'm going to rise to a
very high position in England and in my
high position I will save London
from being bombed how old was he when
this is 16. what do you make of that
that's very specific well it is and he
said it to someone who became a a
minister and who actually wrote it all
down contemporaneously and Andrew
Roberts believes the story well the way
that I interpreted that is that
Churchill was delusional he thought in
this very Schoolboy sort of way that
England was going to come under threat
is not totally implausible that there'd
be a war and that he Winston Spencer
Churchill would be the person who saved
the country
well that was nuts but actually when
Hitler came along and started appearing
to be a menace to Britain who in the
whole of the British establishment would
say we better worry about Hitler almost
nobody else worried about Hitler the
Prime Minister Neville Chamberlain said
Hitler's a man we can do business with
when he gives his word he'll stick to
his word David Lloyd George said the
same thing so did many other writers
including George Bernard Shaw you know
they thought Hitler
may have come up with some ridiculous
ideas in the 1920s but he was beyond
that he wasn't going to do anything bad
but Churchill said mark my words the
Munich agreement in 1938 is a complete
disaster Hitler said he's not going to
invade Czechoslovakia he's not going to
invade Poland don't believe him
and Neville chamber said no he's given
his word his signature to the bit of
paper that I'm carrying his peace in our
time and you know it was complete
rubbish so when Hitler had done his
worst in 1940
the only person that they could choose
to replace Neville Chamberlain was
actually
Churchill the king didn't like it the
majority of a conservative party didn't
like it the labor party didn't like it
because he'd been very rude about the
trade unions and had broken the general
strike in 1926. he was very unpopular
but nevertheless he said this is what we
must do to save the world and he did
it's unbelievable so delusions can be
very helpful sometimes
as I listen to these Grand beliefs and
as the audience listen to these various
Grand beliefs they may have some
questions of their own so the question
number one might be what if I cannot
identify one of these Grand beliefs do I
need to try to identify a belief because
maybe when I was a kid I thought I would
be an astronaut but I'm not an astronaut
how do I go about finding that grand
belief or is the exercise to try to
create a new grand belief that I can
then use or is it both well how would
you answer these questions I don't think
that everyone Tim should actually have
of crime belief I think you'll either
have it or you don't and I don't think
there's much point in trying to
manufacture
a grand belief because
when you're beyond the age of 15 it's
probably pointless anyway the great
value of having a grand belief is that
it changes your whole mindset when
you're very impressionable age
most people when they get Beyond 20 and
all the rest of it would say this is
unrealistic the whole point about a
grand belief is that it's unrealistic
but you don't realize it's unrealistic
and therefore you might possibly achieve
it there were three other instances of
people who in one form or other believed
that they were going to make a lot of
money or be very successful and because
they this is in your sample set in my
sample yeah so the eight people who had
a grand belief under 50. so very very
small numbers but I was staggered I
thought I was the only one with one of
these stupid juvenile beliefs so it's
much more common than perhaps and most
of them had not told anyone else that
they had this um belief I remember there
was one of the ones who had a political
belief said that
his belief was held up to ridicule in
the school assembly after he'd left he
left at age 16 and went to a sixth form
College because he couldn't stand being
in the school which was a very
regimented Traditional School
and he said that the geography Master
stood up in assembly a few months after
he'd left
and said you might know that when people
leave school we ask them why they're
leaving and what their future career is
going to be what job they think they're
going to have in the future and he said
and this person wrote down prime
minister and he said you know it's
ridiculous for one of you to think that
you're going to be prime minister a dick
and when my friend had actually found
out about it he didn't identify who the
person was because
this was someone who left three months
ago you might remember that they left
and they looked like this no he didn't
say that but my friend was incandescent
with sohu reports with anger saying how
dare this man has only been a geography
teacher in his whole career
yes judgment say it's completely
unrealistic for you to become Prime
Minister that just made me more and more
determined become prime minister at
least to get close to it and so these
beliefs are quite visceral I mean they
you know whether they're good loose or
bad Blues I think police at an early
stage they're the flip side of a toxic
belief so for example my actual Grand
belief was that I'd make a lot of money
I'd be a millionaire
but later on I had a toxic belief which
was a variant of that which is nothing
in my life is more important than making
money
and it was so ridiculous that when I had
made a lot of money in in the year 2000
my net worth doubled and it doubled very
much in the last three months and that
was because two companies that I'd
invested in FanDuel and Auto One were
the companies in the case of Auto one
they did an IPO in the first quarter of
the fine year in the case of FanDuel
there was an offer made by flutter which
was in a way descended from Betfair to
buy out the minority stake of which I
was part in FanDuel and it was a very
generous offer so there I was I had 300
million pounds in cash
and my network had gone up to a billion
pounds from from 500 million pounds I'm
sorry if that sounds like boasting but
but the odd thing was I was miserable
and I was miserable because I felt the
responsibility here I'd got this sort of
you know Wonderful track record of 22
compound after tax returns and I just
felt what do I do in the next five to
ten years in order to continue this
track record so there I was desperately
trying to spend this money I invested in
the company we talked about earlier what
three words and made a very large
investment in that and invested in some
other companies and
it was stressful because you know there
was a lot at stake and then I I suddenly
had a realization at the end of that
year this is stupid why should I feel
under stress to make more money when
I've already got more money than I can
possibly spend in my lifetime even
giving away it's going to be you know
quite difficult don't write into me
please and ask me for donations because
I've decided what to do with my money
and it's it's nice it's not one for you
but anyway
how stupid can you be to have a lot of
money and be anxious about it but the
strength of the belief was very strong
and it lasted for a very long time yeah
so you know I do think that these Grand
beliefs can sometimes be toxic Loose as
well how did you pattern interrupt in
the sense that like your experience I've
heard of many experiences in some cases
from acquaintances or friends very often
from others outside of those circles who
get to a point they are what they might
consider post-economic they've worked so
hard or made very smart decisions but
they put a lot of energy into getting to
a point where they don't have to worry
about money and they find new ways to
worry about money yeah right yeah so you
used to be reaching a number they far
surpassed that number and now it's about
their annual compound and annual growth
rate something like that they find a new
way to worry about money they know it's
stupid
but they cannot seem
to stop or they don't have compelling
Alternatives so they keep playing these
dumb games with themselves how did you
interrupt them
it's either very difficult or it's
impossible or it's very easy and this is
a it's the flip side about I buy it so
far I mean I I actually came to when I
was I was thinking about beliefs and I
said you know there are all these uh
toxic beliefs and isn't it strange how
people have got these toxic beliefs and
then I realized I had one myself it was
a variant you know it wasn't I needed to
make money it was very important and it
was the most important thing and I said
to myself
is this going to make me happy so I mean
my only advice to people is to say you
know is it going to make you happy and
also is getting rid of the belief going
to enable you to get rid of some stress
because stress up to a certain point is
very functional but beyond a certain
point it's paralyzing so you ask
yourself a very simple question and we
should ask ourselves is whenever we're
thinking about our lives in a serious
way we should say is it making me happy
what beliefs do I have and is it making
me happy and if it's not making me happy
it's not going to make other people
happy and one of my points about
happiness is that happiness is probably
the least selfish thing that you can
pursue because if you're happy you're
going to make a lot of other people
happy as well if you're miserable yeah
that's a really important you're going
to make other people miserable and
whenever I'm tempted to be a bit
downbeat or misanthropic I say to myself
this is very selfish so get out of this
particular pattern of thinking yeah you
know like Turning Away these sincere
loving listeners who want to ask you for
all of your money
well I know thanks
so I I to scratch an itch that I
mentioned earlier and this is related to
Oxford
so I'm going to give you a cue and then
I'd love for you to unpack it and then I
have a bunch of selfish questions or
self-interested questions at the very
least so the Oxford experience for 99
one people and that's 99 slash one so
think again long lines of 80 20. 99 1
which perhaps you could explain but what
is the Oxford experience for 99 one
people or what could it be I've been
talking to the head of my old College
what is the name of your old College I'd
rather not say it
no I don't know no I don't see why I
shouldn't people can look it up very
easily It's Autumn College Warren
College or w-odh does that expose you in
some strange way I mean it's giving the
game away a little bit it might be
premature because we haven't done it yet
oh yeah I seriously yeah right right so
we could scratch that no no no no no
that's fine don't scratch it it's fine
don't scratch it
so it started because they were
interested in me making a donation to
college and I said yeah fine I can make
a donation to college but rather than
make a donation can I also give you some
thoughts about you know about your
finances and and the head of the college
was very gracious and said yeah that's
fine
we love donations with lots of strings
well I'm just kidding and I said yeah
okay you said we're losing money on our
undergraduates every undergraduate that
we educate costs us twice
what we can actually charge they can
charge that's why 99 200 pounds a year
and we make a loss on that because we've
got a tutorial system a tutorial system
is very labor intensive a tutorial
system means that instead of people
going to lectures what you do is you
have a tutor and either alone or with
one other student you go and see them
every week and they give you a subject
for an essay and they tell you which
books and articles to read and then a
week later you go along to them again
with a bit of fear and trembling and
you've got your essay there and they
don't sort of tell you to hand over they
make you read it out it's a form of
sadism and then they interrupt you
halfway through and say well it's
interesting you say this Richard but
isn't it true that and then they give
you a complete opposite View and you get
challenged and that's very good for you
although it's terrifying to start with
and you can actually get into quite an
intelligent discussion and you as a
student you know 18 year old student
have got the benefit of the personal
attention of someone who's a world
expert in this particular field and
they're telling you
that your thinking is all screwed up or
sometimes very occasionally they tell
you that's really good yes you've got
you're on to something there but have
you also considered the set and the
other
It's a Wonderful system I think I would
never have made the money that I've made
or have whatever success I've had in
life had it not been for that experience
of having that tutorial system so I'm
very happy to to give my old College
some money but I said look let's try and
work out why you're losing money and
they said well it's very simple you know
we're losing money on every
undergraduate okay so I say well
maybe you should have more graduates and
they say no we don't want to do that we
like teaching undergrades we think it's
very useful and we're quite passionate
about that so you've got to continue
teaching these underground why can't you
charge more money we can't charge more
money because that's set by the
government why can't you get more
overseas students we can't get more
overseas students because the regulator
won't allow us to go over a certain
percentage
so then I'm sort of running out of ideas
and then I said to look
Oxford terms last for eight weeks don't
they and they said yes and there's three
terms a year so even I can do the mental
arithmetic that three times eight is 24.
that's 24 weeks of the year that you're
actually operating this educational
Factory let's call it a factory
and again even I can work out that the
capacity utilization on that basis is 46
you know you're closed more than you are
open is there a way of doing it and I
said well let's think about the 80 20
principle the 80 20 principle says that
if you want a new set of customers you
might as well go for the customers that
can afford the most and can benefit the
most so I'm going to call these people
99 one people so what you want to do is
go and talk to the most very successful
companies
in Britain and throughout the world
and identify the very most successful
people within those companies very
probably they're going to be the people
at the top of the company aren't they or
they're close to the top of the company
okay it's become quite fashionable and I
think very useful for people to have a
period of sabbaticals you know this
originated I think in Academia itself
but more and more companies are very
successful companies investment Banks
consulting firms even Venture Capital
firms marketing experts anyone who's
found a corner where they've got a very
high relative market share they're very
successful at doing what they're doing
they're making pots and pots of money
but the people who at the top of those
companies actually very often who've
been responsible for making lots and
lots of money are exhausted volcanoes
that you know they're basically they've
been doing the same thing for the last
10 years they need some new ideas and
they also need a break so one of the
things that my old firms
alike got a guy called Stuart Jackson
who became the chief executive long
after I disappeared and he said you've
got to have a three-month sabbatical
every five years it's not optional
you know you've got to do it and you've
got to do something which refreshes your
mind as well as your body and all the
rest of it so I think perfect what we'll
do is we'll do sabbaticals for people
who have been very very successful and
what are we going to do we're not going
to talk about business
because most of the people who are good
Target markets for this what I call the
Oxford experience or the wadham
experience are going to be people who in
One Way or Another relate to business
they don't have to be in business but if
they're going to make a lot of money you
know they could in theory be
um artists or they you know they they
could be brain surgeons most likely
they're going to be related to business
so what we're going to do is set up a
course which has nothing whatsoever to
do with business but which is a good
intellectual training and so let's come
up with a list of 10 things that you can
teach that people might be interested in
buying and they came up with a list and
it includes things like the history of
art it's amazing how many people who
have been very successful and know
nothing at all about art actually want
to study the history of art it's a very
it's a very fashionable subject these
days so there's history of art there's
philosophy you know again that's a lot
of interest as you know in Greek and
Roman philosophy so let's study
philosophy and see what they had to say
about this
there's also things like the history of
the last 300 years again and quite a few
people have said to me including former
investment bankers
my weak suit is actually history I've
got no context for the modern world I
don't understand how the modern world
developed other people said what about
psychology or sociology and so on so
that you know we've got a list of 10
possible options oh meditation
meditation is enormously important but
some intellectual Grist behind it it's
not it's not just sort of you know
touchy-feely sort of stuff you know
there are some really profound roots to
meditation and you have to understand
the history of Buddhism and etc etc etc
can you teach that yes we can teach that
so what I said was okay what we do is we
get people to come from organizations we
mix them up in terms of background and
we put them in Triads when in trios
groups of three people and then they
have the tutorial system and they come
and they agree to study you know the
same subject for eight weeks at the 17th
century beautiful 17th Century College
bottom College Oxford were the most
wonderful Gardens behind never mind that
the weather is terrible people going to
really benefit from this experience and
we'll do it in the spring and the summer
so that's all right so you don't have to
worry about that my main question that I
wrote down in preparation for hearing
all about this was best time of year
question mark
well it's the spring and summer vocation
so it's basically from May June July
August September yeah so those are the
times that it's safe to go to England
and that book
and if you live there anyway it doesn't
make any difference yeah sure if you're
already there it doesn't matter how
would you think about it I understand
this hasn't been decided but how would
you think about pricing something like
that just for a window into oh are you
very expensive no my idea is that we
throw in
everything the tuition we throw in lots
of food we throw in the accommodation in
this 17th century beautiful building
slightly impractical
and we throw in food and most important
of all we throw in lots of wine because
we've got wine cellars which are very
Fine Wines
and we make it a very enjoyable
experience and we also have weekly
lectures and apart from the tutorials
but the tutorial is the sort of you know
Bedrock thing and how do we price it we
charge fifty thousand pounds yeah so
it's about 70 000 or something like that
yeah and it's a lot of money but for an
organization that's been very successful
and is thinking about sending you know
half a dozen people it's nothing it's a
it's an absolute Drop in the Ocean and
if one of those people comes up with a
creative idea which is going to generate
a new product or a new way of doing
business comparable perhaps to what
Bruce Henderson or Bill Bain came up
with you know as a result of thinking
that's what they did you know they
thought very carefully and they were
very bright people you know if they come
up with an idea like that as a result of
the sabbatical it's going to pay for
itself many many times over and also the
other great attribute is that we'll
organize people into groups of three
people they can't be from the same
organization they have to be from a
different background and they have to be
from a different country and
it's going to be a very intense
experience for those three people and
they're going to get to know each other
they might hate each other a result of
the eight weeks they spend together but
they might become best friends or they
might work out a business rationale
whether organizations in some way can
collaborate with each other so this is a
wonderful idea and you know they should
be queuing up so anyone who's very
interested in this contact me and I'll
put you in touch with the warden of
Warden and he can sign you up for this
he should figure out a contact form so
you're not getting seven million emails
about this we'll figure that out we'll
put something in the show notes and let
me ask you then a couple of well a few
ideas I'll throw out some ideas too so
there's there's an event that I've
attended before called dialogue and I
haven't been in a while but in the early
days especially I really enjoyed it when
the groups were smaller and thinking
about oh man if I ended up kind of like
the movie Step Brothers or people have
seen that it's comedy but
bunking you know if one of my two team
members of the triplets if I didn't get
along with one but I had to see them
every day for eight weeks I might just
leave I might pull the rip cord if I'm
being honest with myself but with the
one not saying alternative maybe it's a
compliment just to diversify the
interactions but what dialogue does very
well is they have assigned seating for
every meal and they decide on the
composition of each table and then one
person is tasked with this is typically
for dinners
leading the conversation so there's one
conversation per table Jeffersonian
style so in this case it's generally
more than three people so it'd be five
or six or seven or something like that
and it's absolutely spectacular it makes
such a big difference I will say
that if there's the possibility if I
could put in a bespoke request
no not a freebie I'll pay but the I
think there would be a huge demand also
from entrepreneurs maybe they are the
CEOs of companies they've built who are
looking for
a
defensible
excuse they need something that will not
look like unemployment on LinkedIn for
say one or two or three months
to rest themselves and get out of the
exhausted volcano category right I think
there would also be a huge demand for
that as far as upside and financial
possibilities that's all great and
that's icing on the cake but they just
want a [__] break
hang out and have some wine around can
you imagine working in a high pressure
Organization for 20 years chlorine your
way to the top of that organization and
then finding that they still want you to
work 50 or 60 hours a week oh yeah 50
well not 52 weeks a year but maybe 48 oh
sure I mean and then on your time off
you're thinking about this yeah and then
you're only an option to go from mega
mega work is you retire and then you've
got nothing to do yeah so yeah it's
people who claw that effectively it's
really stupid and you know don't do well
in retirement General so my my best
request which is more of a suggestion
but it ends up happening then I will
certainly participate if there were in
addition to history of Art and art
option there was more Hands-On so I'll
get very specific here if you could
bring in some people
who were formerly or currently but
probably formerly given the duration say
artists concept artists background
artists Etc from places like Pixar and
maybe you had a couple of different
tranches right there was say very very
beginner starting from scratch folks who
were doing gesture drawing and so on
using traditional materials but then
also having some folks who are bringing
in digital tools which is has been a
huge key to unlocking my ability to
enjoy art again it's the ability to hit
undo
my God is that a lifesaver I would
absolutely participate in that and I I
would probably participate in other
things language for instance if there
were an option to really just focus on
that it sounds lovely so in any case I
think that's no I think your request is
right I mean I think art is hugely
important I absolutely believe the
western civilization would not be what
it is today if it had not been for the
Renaissance and the artists and you know
we wouldn't have all these beautiful
churches with with the frescoes and you
know we wouldn't have lots of things and
art moves on you know and arts I don't
know it's it's probably as cumulative to
a degree because people invent
perspective for example and then all the
art looks a lot more interesting and
then people do Tech stuff so you know
that it's another dimension on all right
so it's Progressive but it's also there
are different periods you know even
Picasso had about six different periods
of it of his life he didn't always draw
people like they were you know sliced up
so you know it's it I think art is
enormously important don't forget
artists either you know I mean I happen
to know one of my best friends is an
artist who's got two paintings in the
Tate not the modern one but the old one
that has taped Britain is what they call
it now yeah I've been sure he would be
delighted to come along and talk to
people and look at the art of Someone
Like You I mean like you showed me some
of the pictures yet that you've been
drawing
yesterday and I thought they were
fantastic I actually I said to myself I
want to show that to Colin Smith who's
the Chapman involved I'd really like to
introduce you to him because he might
think they're they're no good but I
doubt it you know and I I think people
need encouragement people do need
encouragement and I actually I'm gonna
this is very much out of left field but
I want to put it out there if you are an
artist specifically a comic book artist
or if you're involved with sequential
art in Portugal please ping me on
Twitter because last night I'm not gonna
name names but the girlfriend of a
mutual friend of ours showed me art that
was made by a seven-year-old here in
Portugal that blew my mind this kid has
so much potential he's so incredibly
developed for his age I don't think he's
had any formal training whatsoever it's
incredible and it would just be such it
would make me so happy to try to connect
him with someone in Portugal who's
walking the walk and is doing what he
dreams of doing because I think he could
be one of the greats I mean it sounds
like a very big statement it is but I
was absolutely Blown Away by how
talented this kid is so I'm not that kid
but I do know that I have some
predisposition I've resurrected this
interest this love
and to have these experts who are
practitioners who love what they do who
are not just teaching material right
because you could go and try to memorize
Wikipedia for material but they're
imbuing you with a sense of excitement
and passion and love and ultimately
hopefully helping you to develop
confidence so that you can actually
continue exploring these things I just I
love everything about it yeah and I
think it's very important for business
as well because business is increasingly
a matter of beauty I mean you think
about the Apple devices though they are
beautiful at a certain level and you
know Steve Jobs apparently took the
people to MoMA and New York Museum of
Modern Art and said you know what we
want to do is create things which are in
the same category that sounds like a
crazy left field sort of thing to do but
it worked you know and they did create
you know I think the iPhone is actually
quite a beautiful thing job studied
calligraphy also and I will say that
there are the direct
implications of Art and I was reading an
excellent book I'm blanking on the name
it's about the function and history of
comics really wish I could remember the
author's name but I read this book and I
believe it was in this book that he
talked about art and defined it as
anything that does not have human
produced art as anything that does not
have a Fitness function in the sense of
reproduction or survival anything that
falls outside of that anything that's
not utilitarian in other words the only
thing that's not useful yeah yeah yeah
in a narrow possible sense but what is
more useful than Beauty all right I
don't object here but I'm saying so we
could we could definitely go down a
rabbit hole I think we need more wine
for that maybe tonight we'll have a good
argument about this what I was going to
make we haven't had any so far good Lord
yeah I think I think I'm a white belt
signing up to spar the black belt here
but the the point I was going to make is
there are the obvious connections right
Steve Jobs stays calligraphy that
informs the typefaces of the Macintosh
Etc et cetera but then there are these
perhaps non-obvious radiating effects
that I've experienced where
I'm getting involved with playing around
with painting I mean I spent two and a
half hours digitally painting something
yesterday it was very challenging I made
all sorts of mistakes but I was
completely engrossed in it and lost in a
way may be found in a way that I often
experience in deep states of meditation
but I'm not going to meditate for two
and a half hours on a daily basis this
was effortless in a sense and if you
could imagine what if I could accrue
some say the benefits of meditating for
two hours a day while doing something
else
or put in a more maybe concrete sense
you know recharging your batteries what
would you do with that extra energy so
what I found is by doing this thing
which even some of my friends have said
they haven't labeled it frivolous but
they're like okay man hey whatever
floats your boat fine that's great you
know enjoy it hello dog am I speaking
your language do you like Beauty too
the dog is wagging her too oh what a
lovely Pooch I have experienced this new
Wellspring of energy
which I can then apply to everything so
it's also helping me to grow this
fundamental
underlying currency of energy that then
applies to everything else it's just
been incredible so I do hope people are
able to find more options for themselves
and I want to mention one thing before I
forget which is if you want to delve
into history maybe we can get some
recommendations from YouTube but one of
my favorite ways to delve into history
in the last
10 years has been listening to what is
still my favorite podcast it's an oldie
but goodie Hardcore History by Dan
Carlin I had him on the podcast
interviewed him ages ago I suggest that
people could start there are series on
World War One series and World War II
but I really enjoyed
prophets of Doom is one option they're
very long they're like audiobooks in
this case this is probably four hours
long profits of Doom which talks about
Lutheran reformation and all sorts of
craziness that happen subsequent to that
in Germany which you can listen to and
Wrath of the cons which is about Genghis
Khan I think is the pronunciation they
use in that and it's four or five
episodes on the Mongols and Genghis Khan
who was an incredibly fascinating
incredibly intelligent very
sophisticated strategist not necessarily
just the sort of folklorian brute that
many people associate his name with
Richard is there anything else that you
would like to talk about before we wind
to a close and maybe perhaps grab a bite
to eat is there anything else that we
should discuss anything else I didn't
ask that you'd like to touch on anything
at all there is one other thing which is
I'm not only writing one book I'm
writing another book at the same time
and this book is called 80 20 daily I
know that your interest in stoicism for
example and they've been very successful
set of daily readings so you have 365
readings
it's a it's a it's very good it's a
little tedious after a certain time but
I said well why wouldn't it be a good
idea to have a set of readings related
to not just the 80 20 principle but when
I call the 80 20 philosophy because
without being too grandiose I do think
there are huge depths which I haven't
plumbed personally I'm sure there's far
more there about the 80 20 principle you
remember that when it was first
suggested to me that I write about the
80 20 principle I told the editor who
was concerned I could probably spin it
out to about five pages but I certainly
couldn't write a book I ended up writing
four books about it and they're not
desperately repetitive I think they're
maybe slightly repetitive but I've set
myself of the task of writing 365
ideas about life the universe and
everything which are related in some way
some some people might say rather
tenuous way in some cases but which are
fundamentally related to 80 20. and to
me 80 20 is far more than a technocratic
thing and it's about creating a better
life for yourself and for other people
and to do that you need to be able to
get results in a way which is very
highly productive so it sounds
technocratic but it's actually quite
deep
so for example you were talking a few
minutes ago about the impact of Art in
terms of increasing energy well I think
that's a very 80 20 Concept in itself
totally I haven't got one of the
365 daily readings about that but I will
have I think by the time I've finished
anyway this book is going to come out
next year as indeed 80 20 beliefs is
going to come out it's going to be
sensationally successful with putting my
optimistic hat on my marketing and
investment hat on and I actually think
people will find it very very
interesting and if you don't blame me
because I've tried hard to make it every
single one is about a different subject
but they're all related to each other in
one way or another through the 80 20
principle and it's attempt to say it's
about living so there's a lot of stuff
in there which says one way or another
don't work too hard there's a lot of
stuff which says one way or another
don't follow the rules Break The Rules
there's a lot of sort of you know
non-conformist in a way it's I suppose
it goes back to the sort of you know
flower power and all that you know which
I think is you know much misunderstood I
think that the attempt to stimulate
creativity and get out of the straight
jacket of working too hard and being
monochrome and boring you know I think
business is not boring and monochrome
and the people in the 1950s who did it
did it one way but we can do it in a
multi-colored and much more enjoyable
way
get enjoyment out of life but also do
things which are going to help other
people in one way of giving them ideas
or giving them inspiration or whatever
anyway so that's my little advertisement
as you Americans would say
uh for 80 20 days that's an
advertisement oh wait I'm American I did
it
I will be first in line your writing
I've said this before I'll say it again
your writing is a huge impact on my life
and I will certainly be first in line
for both of these 80 20 daily and 80 20
beliefs it never gets old it always
Bears repeating reinforcing
re-contextualizing seeing in new
situations and scenarios the 80 20
principle power law distributions
they're everywhere it's not
limited to business at all business just
happens to be at times a very
crystalline chessboard on which you can
see things that are hard to see in other
places but it shows up in biology it
shows up in every aspect of life you can
possibly imagine and for that reason I
will continue to read and reread your
work and think about these things and
journaling these things they're so
incredibly
powerful and so
leveraged if you want to mimic
Archimedes and find a lever long enough
that you can move the world
you have to pick the right rocks to put
them under and you have to choose the
right levers and these are principles
that are incredibly helpful for doing
that yeah well thank you very much
indeed to my I can't say thank you
enough that's I'm very grateful to you
thank you absolutely and two everybody
listening
you can find Richard
richardkosh.net that's
richardkoch.net you can find him on
Twitter at Richard
kosh8020 the new books are 80 20 beliefs
and 80 20 daily
as always we will have show notes at
tim.blog podcast with links to
everything
and until next time be just a little
Kinder than necessary not just to others
but also to your self yeah sometimes
that involves cross-examining your
thoughts not believing everything you
think
and thank you all for tuning in take
care everybody thank you
hey guys this is Tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet Friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bullet Friday easy to sign
up easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that I send out every Friday to
share the coolest things I've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles I'm reading books I'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that get sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcasts guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then I test them and then I share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about if
you'd like to try it out just go to
tim.com Friday type that into your
browser Tim dot blog slash Friday drop
in your email and you'll get the very
next one thanks for listening
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep temperature is one of the main
causes of poor sleep and heat is my
personal Nemesis I've suffered for
decades tossing and turning throwing
blankets off pulling the back on putting
one leg on top and repeating all that ad
nauseam but now I am falling asleep in
record time why because I'm using a
device is recommended to be by friends
called the Pod cover by eight sleep the
Pod cover fits on any mattress and
allows you to adjust the temperature of
your sleeping environment providing the
optimal temperature that gets you the
best night's sleep with the Pod covers
Dual Zone temperature control you and
your partner can set your sides of the
bed to as cool as 55 degrees or as hot
as 110 degrees I think generally in my
experience my partners prefer the high
side and I like to sleep very very cool
so stop fighting this helps based on
your Biometrics environment and sleep
stages the Pod cover makes temperature
adjustments throughout the night that
limit wake-ups and increase your
percentage of deep sleep in addition to
its best class temperature regulation
the Pod cover sensors also track your
health and sleep metrics without the
need to use a wearable so go to
atesleep.com Tim allspelled out
eightsleep.com Tim and save 250 on the
eight sleep pod cover that's
eightsleep.com Tim eight sleep currently
ships within the US Canada and the UK
select countries in the EU and Australia
again that's eightsleep.com Tim to save
250 on the eight sleep pod cover
this episode is brought to you by secure
frame secure frames industry-leading
compliance automation platform paired
with their in-house compliance experts
and former Auditors helps you to get
audit ready in weeks not months so you
can close more deals faster I pulled a
ton of you online on social and reviews
came back which were overwhelmingly
positive for secure firm secure frame
simplifies and streamlines the process
of getting and staying compliant to the
most rigorous Global privacy and
security standards they help thousands
of businesses achieve compliance with
security and privacy Frameworks
including sock 2 ISO 27001 HIPAA PCI and
gdpr secure frame is the most
comprehensive security and compliance
automation platform with hundreds of
Integrations built-in security training
vendor and risk management and more you
continuously detect and remediate
misconfigurations across your technology
stack you also get complete visibility
with actionable insights on critical
security and privacy compliance issues
security training for sock 2 HIPAA PCI
DSS gdpr and more are built into secure
frames platform you can quickly meet
security and privacy compliance
requirements and saves time assigning
tracking and Reporting on required
training secureframe provides unmatched
expert guidance every step of the way
with their 30 plus former Auditors and
Industry professionals secureframe helps
you quickly achieve and maintain
compliance so you can focus on other
things like serving your customers
scaling your business and growing
Revenue so consider automating your
security and privacy compliance with
secureframe schedule a demo today at
secureframe.com as it sounds
secureframe.com and tell them Tim
Ferriss that's me Tim Ferriss sent you
to unlock 10 off for your first year
again that's secureframe.com and during
your demo tell them that Tim Ferriss
sent you to unlock 10 off for your first
year one more time secureframe.com
foreign
[Applause]